So. Eats.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Oh, ich muss mal grad hier... bisschen was verrücken.
Ganz schepp. Ich hoffe, ich schmeiß jetzt das Teile nicht runter.
Hopp. So.
Ja, jetzt viel besser. Jetzt steht mein Stuhl wenigstens wieder ordentlich.
Jack White.
Ah, ja, Leute.
Heute bin ich fast 40 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren wieder.
Nicht so heftig wie letzte Woche mit den 51 Kilometern und dabei den Berg rauf.
Aber es macht schon mega Bock.
Man gewöhnt sich vor allem schon ein bisschen dran.
Ich hab's heute gemerkt. Es war heute viel einfacher, bisschen schneller zu fahren schon.
Und auch das...
Nicht so, dass ich gleich beim Losfahren im Oberschenkel merke, dass ich mir denk, boah, Alter, ist das anstrengend.
Ja, richtig Eats.
Ah, ja. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich da bin heute.
Ihr wisst ja, es ist Samstag. Da bin ich manchmal bis 23 Uhr da.
Notes.
Es ist 2023. Wo bist du denn gelandet?
Bist du bei irgendeinem Amt?
Bist du bei irgendeinem Amt oder irgendwas bei...
Also, wie kommt... Also, wo muss man landen?
Ohne, dass ich jetzt den Namen sagen muss.
Aber wo muss man landen, dass 2023 noch Lotus Notes verwendet wird?
Sag mal so grob.
So Branche oder sowas. Also, ich hätte ja fast gedacht, bei irgendeinem Amt oder so.
Chris, danke für den Sub.
Aufwärmen ist auch beim Rennen nicht ohne, hab ich gemerkt.
Ich bin eine ganze Zeit lang jetzt einfach morgens vor die Tür, hab die Uhr gestartet, bin losgerannt.
Wenn man ein bisschen sich aufwärmt, bringt auf jeden Fall schon einigen.
Okay, das ist nicht wirklich ein Amt, oder? Das ist aber, sag mal so, es geht in die Richtung von Amt.
Oh man, Lotus Notes. Und warum benutzen die heute noch Lotus Notes?
Haben die so viele Eigenentwicklungen da drauf, dass sie nicht woanders umsteigen können, oder?
Anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen. Also, Notes ist wirklich absoluter Abpack.
Also, war es schon immer.
Aber wer sich damit 2023 noch umschlagen muss, der hat echt gelitten.
Muss deine Uni Pflicht SAP-Vorlesung machen?
Hä? SAP-Vorlesung? Es gibt SAP-Vorlesung?
Sponsort SAP die Uni, oder was?
Hast du die Steckdose von... was?
Knows mal ausprobiert gehabt?
Hab ich mir die bestellt?
Ja, das haben wir doch sogar im Stream ausprobiert, oder?
Oder nicht?
Ich bin mir da jetzt nicht mehr sicher.
Also, eine habe ich aufgemacht.
Eine habe ich aufgemacht und habe geflasht.
Das hat funktioniert.
Falls das die waren, die du meinst.
Ja, E-Mail Client. Also, Notes ist grausam.
Ich glaube, das schlechteste an Notes ist der E-Mail Client.
Also, Notes ist ja im Prinzip Datenbank plus Anwendungsframework plus E-Mail.
Aber die E-Mail Funktion ist wirklich mega beschissen, Alter.
Access. Ja, was denn sonst?
Das sind bestimmt auch die, die der Meinung sind, dass Excel quasi das Tool der Wahl für nahezu alles Organisatorische ist.
Das Thema ist, mir tun die Beine noch ein bisschen weh vom Rumfahren und wir schwätzen eine Runde.
Vielleicht, falls ihr irgendwelche Stellenanzeigen habt, könnt ihr schicken, können wir uns angucken.
Ansonsten gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
Oder, wobei, das frage ich gleich, wenn noch ein paar mehr Leute da sind.
Ich bin nämlich gerade was eingefallen.
Ich kann es ja aber schon mal spoilern.
Ich hatte heute meine GoPro an beim Fahrradfahren.
Aber das frage ich nachher dann.
Wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Ja, Lotus Notes wird noch weiterentwickelt.
Aber Lotus Notes ist nicht mal Lotus Notes.
Sondern genau, es ist HC...
Oh, meine Augen, Alter.
Krass, das geht ja nicht.
Das nennt sich jetzt HCL Notes.
Davor war es sogar IBM Notes.
Und davor war es Lotus Notes.
Aktuelle Version. Oh, guck mal.
Nicht mal der neue Hersteller hat Bock da drauf.
Oh, guck mal. Notes basiert auf Java, C++, C und HTML.
Das ist ja mal eine geile Mischung, Alter.
Was ist das für eine Mischung?
Das ist ja komplett random einfach jetzt.
Wilde Mischung, ja.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das eine Five-Hand-Mischung ist.
Das ist eine absolute Paint-Champ-Mischung.
Ja, es ist...
Eigentlich ist es so ein Anwendungsframework.
Die meisten Leute benutzen es aber als E-Mail und Kalender.
Im Prinzip benutzen es die meisten Leute als Outlook-Ersatz.
Oder viele Unternehmen haben das gemacht.
Aber die sind mittlerweile auch drauf gekommen,
dass es eigentlich Schrott ist.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind...
Was ist das denn hier?
Lasst uns doch gerade mal checken.
Bestes Website-Design aller Zeiten.
Lotus Notes.
Einsam und alleine auf Platz 1.
So muss das sein.
Aber Microsoft Teams ist auch relativ weit vorne.
SAP R3.
Also ich checke bei SAP ja absolut null, was da der Unterschied ist.
Es gibt R3, es gibt HANA, es gibt noch...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Oh, Helpline!
Helpline hat das auch verdient.
Helpline ist das größte Abfuck-Ticketsystem, was ich je verwenden musste.
Also das, was mir mit Abstand, wirklich mit riesen Abstand, am wenigsten gefallen hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch da mal Screenshots von gezeigt habe.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist es nicht.
Das ist...
Das sieht alles zu neu aus.
Okay, vielleicht sieht es mittlerweile neu aus, aber...
Es war Windows-Only damals.
Windows-Desktop-Client-Only.
Ja, das sieht schon eher so aus.
Windows-Desktop-Client...
Ja! Nee.
Nee.
Nee, das ist SolarWinds.
Lul.
Nee, nee, das ist was anderes.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Schrott.
Alles Schrott.
Helpline ist...
Keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt.
Ich will es auch gar nicht wissen.
Ich hoffe, dieses Ticketsystem muss ich nie wieder mitarbeiten und nie wieder sehen.
Kann man nicht auch einfach selbst sich den Nextcloud hosten und damit Mail und Orga machen?
Nein, kann man nicht.
Also, nicht von den Funktionen, was du brauchst, um größere Sachen zu managen.
Also, es gibt ja sicherlich ein paar, die probieren das mit Nextcloud.
Vielleicht kommen die einen oder anderen damit durch.
Aber ich bezweifle es.
Ich bezweifle es.
Ich meine, den Teil von Nextcloud, den du benutzen willst, für Mail und Orga...
Für Mail schon mal gar nicht.
Für Orga vielleicht CalDAV.
Aber da gibt es einfach zu wenig Ökosystem drumherum.
Auch wenn es das einzige, meines Wissens nach so Open Source...
Nein, nicht Open Source.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ja, Open...
Spezifikationsmäßig...
Protokoll für Orga-Sachen ist...
Ne, ne.
Das kannst du knicken.
Man muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen, es hat einen Grund, warum die meisten Unternehmen heutzutage Exchange bzw. Outlook in Kombination mit Exchange oder Outlook in Kombination mit irgendwelchen Microsoft-hosted Sachen dafür verwenden.
Es integriert sich einfach gar nicht.
Da sage ich als jemand, der wirklich...
Ich hasse Outlook.
Ich hasse die ganze Microsoft-Office-Geschichte.
Ich raste aus immer, wenn ich das benutzen muss für irgendwas.
Aber...
Also...
Insgesamt für Enterprise-Umgebung verstehe ich das schon.
Du kannst da wohl sehr genau administratorisch einstellen, was wie wo geregelt ist.
Es gibt ein riesen Ökosystem drumherum.
Und die Leute kennen sich gut mit Outlook aus.
Outlook hat soweit alle Funktionen.
Das ganze kannst du auch mobile verwenden.
Also insofern...
Ich verstehe das schon irgendwie.
Und das integriert sich halt wunderbar in das ganze Office 365-Ökosystem, was eh die meisten Unternehmen benutzen.
Also ich raste...
Leute, ich mag es wirklich nicht.
Aber ich erkenne, warum sie es verwenden.
Ja.
HANA ist das Space Upgrade.
Der alte Shit ist R3, der auch ERP genannt wird.
Aha.
Und alles hat man...
Und alles programmiert man mit ABAP, oder?
Ich finde den Hate gegen Teams unberechtigt.
Ich auch.
Oh, Webex!
Alter, Webex.
Hör mal bloß auf.
Webex war ganz schrecklich.
Also ich...
Also ich gette den Hate gegen Teams.
Teams hat viele nervige Sachen.
Vor allem, bisher zumindest, die Performance, die absolut grottenschlecht ist.
Oder zumindest bei mir auf der aktuellen Arbeit.
Aber da läuft im Hintergrund ja auch irgendwie 500-Viren-Scanner.
Aber davor auch schon.
Aber insgesamt, muss ich ehrlich sagen, wenn ich das mal vergleiche, so mit Skype früher, ist Teams doch schon um Längen angenehmer.
Auch wenn ich es mal mit Zoom vergleiche.
Chatge, jemand von euch, der regelmäßig Zoom verwenden muss?
Also ich hatte bisher erst einmal im professionellen Business-Enterprise-Fi-Fight-Umfeld die Ehre Teams verwenden zu müssen.
Äh, nicht Teams, Zoom verwenden zu müssen.
Oh, das hat mich wirklich genervt.
Also Zoom war eigentlich nicht das.
Und ich meine, ich persönlich würde am liebsten Discord verwenden, aber da kann man natürlich zu wenig einstellen.
Und integriert sich auch nicht gut genug ins Business-Enterprise-Ökosystem.
Ich würde einfach Discord für alles benutzen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Dann sagen die Leute, ja, aber Discord kann dann alle Nachrichten mitlesen.
Und dann denke ich mir so, Microsoft kann sicherlich auch alle Nachrichten mitlesen.
Aber sie bieten halt Verträge für an, wo drin steht, dass sie es nicht machen.
Oder was auch immer.
Ja, also ich finde Nextcloud grausam.
Ich persönlich benutze gar kein Nextcloud.
Ich mache einen riesen Bogen um Nextcloud.
Nextcloud wirkt auf mich seit Jahren, also auch schon OnCloud damals,
wirkt auf mich einfach als gut gedacht, aber nie wirklich zu Ende implementierte,
eine Sammlung aus gut gedachten, aber nie wirklich zu Ende implementierten Ideen.
Ich glaube, das fasst Nextcloud ganz gut zusammen.
Und seit den letzten paar Jahren, finde ich, wird Nextcloud für den Privateinsatz immer unattraktiver,
weil sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen, okay, sie wollen Geld machen, ich verstehe es, ja,
jetzt versuchen damit irgendwie so ins Business-Enterprise-Umfeld zu gehen.
Und das, ich weiß nicht, also ganz ehrlich, ne.
Ne, weiß nicht.
Was?
Was soll ich mir angucken?
Systemhaus One.
Moment, es gibt wirklich ein Ticketsystem, was Systemhaus One heißt.
Ne, was ist das?
Öh! Öh!
Also, ich kenne die Software nicht.
Aber es gibt so gewisse Sachen, wenn ich die schon sehe, dann habe ich keinen Bock, die zu verwenden.
Ist das jetzt im Browser?
Ne, Moment, das ist eine reine Desktopanwendung, die über RDP läuft,
also zumindest hier auf den Beispielen.
Ja, XP-Optik, das geht irgendwie noch.
Boah, ne, also allein schon Windows-Only-Clienter drehe ich durch.
Ich kenne das aber nicht, vielleicht ist das gut, keine Ahnung.
Mit den Kacheln sieht ein bisschen aus wie Lotus Notes.
Ich habe es nur im Browser benutzt.
Ja, die Amis benutzen viel Zoom, ich weiß.
Was, Zoom kann ich copy-pasten?
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, dass Teams das gerade ausrollt,
aber so schnell, wie ich die Softwareverteilung und Genehmigungsprozesse und das Etablieren neuer Software bei mir auf der Arbeit einschätze,
wird das wahrscheinlich noch ungefähr 15 Jahre dauern, bis wir das nächste Teams haben.
Gibt es eine lustige Geschichte dazu?
Und zwar, ein Hersteller, ein Third-Party-Hersteller, hat uns Mobile-Apps bereitgestellt.
Und das haben die über irgend so ein komisches, ich will es jetzt nicht genauer erzählen,
über irgend so ein komisches Softwareverteilverfahren gemacht.
Und dafür hat man halt ein Tool gebraucht, das ist ein Open-Source-Tool, das gibt es auf GitHub.
Also im Prinzip stellen die ihre Anwendungen bereit in einem, ich nenne es jetzt mal Docker-Repo,
aber es sind keine Docker-Images, es sind quasi Anwendungen als Docker-Images verpackt.
Und im Prinzip benutzen die die Docker-Registry irgendwie zum Verteilen von Anwendungen.
Fragt mich nicht, was das für ein komisches System ist,
es ist aber wohl recht beliebt, es hat glaube ich irgendwie 700, 800 GitHub-Sterne,
was auch immer die da machen.
Zumindest habe ich dann halt gesagt, okay, also mein Thema zu mir,
Max, kannst du uns mal die neuesten Mobile-Apps runterladen, wir wollen die ausprobieren.
Sag ich, mache ich.
Und danach ging es darum, an dieses Tool, was ich dafür verwenden muss,
das ist nicht offiziell onboarded bei uns in der Firma.
Und dann darf man das Tool eigentlich gar nicht verwenden.
Da habe ich halt auch gefragt, ja, was mache ich jetzt?
Ich meine, ich kann das einfach bei mir auf meiner Linux-Kiste wegjetten und ausführen,
das ist kein Problem, aber wir verwenden da ein nicht ongeboardetes Tool.
Und dann meinte unser Projektmanagement, ah, das ist kein Problem.
Ich bezweifle ehrlich gesagt, dass das kein Problem ist.
Und jetzt wollen sie es versuchen zu onboarden, damit man das offiziell verwenden kann.
Und das ist vor drei Monaten.
Also im Monat, nachdem ich da war, wurde der Prozess angestoßen, das neue Tool zu onboarden.
Bis jetzt ist da noch nichts passiert.
Also wenn das alles in der Geschwindigkeit geht, vermute ich mal, das neue Teams haben wir frühestens 2025.
Teams ins AD, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung von Teams.
Also wir haben vielleicht nicht 500 Viren-Scanner, das war übertrieben.
Aber wir haben sicherlich 5 Viren-Scanner und Security-Sachen im Hintergrund laufen.
Und ich meine, wir haben auf der Arbeit ein echt fettes Notebook.
Das ist ein Core i7, 32 Gig RAM, SSD, also das ist wirklich ein schlechtes Notebook.
Also Hardware-Specs ist wirklich nice.
Also die sind wirklich gut.
Aber es ist so abfuck langsam, wegen dem ganzen Krempel, der da im Hintergrund läuft.
Das ist komplett der Wahnsinn.
Aber vielleicht, auch wenn sich das jetzt ein bisschen negativ anhört.
So negativ ist das alles gar nicht.
Es hat durchaus auch seine Vorteile, wenn zumindest die Abläufe und Prozesse klar definiert sind.
Da kommt es wenigstens nicht vor, wie bei dem Laden davor, wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Übrigens Max, morgen früh oder heute, gleich um 9 geht der neue Service live.
Und alle gucken sich so an, wie welcher Service denn?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Da guckst du in die Dokuseite rein, die in der Checkliste auf grün steht.
Und machst die Seite auf und stellst fest, die Seite ist leer.
Okay, das muss ich kurz erzählen.
Damit ihr den Gag da drum versteht.
Also, in dem letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
da gab es immer mal wieder vor, dass irgendwelche Leute so hinten rum was gebastelt haben.
Und dann ging das einfach live.
Und damit das nicht mehr vorkommt, hatte das Management die grandiose Idee.
Und die war ja auch wirklich, kann man auch sagen, die war jetzt auch nicht total abwegig.
Hatte die Idee, jetzt gibt es sogenannte, wie haben sie das genannt?
Qualitygate.
Qualitygate, das klingt auch nach Fifed, BWL, Enterprise Begriff.
So, ein Qualitygate haben sie sich überlegt.
Das ist im Prinzip eine Checkliste, die abgehakt werden muss, damit ein Produkt live gehen kann.
Und einer dieser Punkte in diesem Qualitygate war Dokumentation.
Da stand dann drinnen, es muss ein, ich habe vergessen, wie sie es genannt haben.
Das waren drei Punkte unter Dokumentation.
Es muss irgendwie ein Eskalationsverfahren geben.
Also sprich, wen ruft man an, was wird gemacht, wenn das Service kaputt geht.
Es müssen generell Ansprechpartner und quasi Servicezeiten und solche Geschichten definiert sein.
Und das dritte war, es muss eine Dokumentation geben, unter anderem auch für den Support.
Wo man halt nachgucken kann, was ist denn das überhaupt?
Was macht denn das?
Wer benutzt denn das so?
Und wie integriert sich das in andere Systeme?
Das sollte eigentlich beschrieben sein drin.
So, und jetzt lief das so, neues Produkt soll live gehen.
Und die Leute müssen das Qualitygate ausfüllen.
Und dann hat sich jetzt nach einer Zeit das so eingebürgert, dass die Leute, da gab es dann ein Ticketworkflow.
Für das Qualitygate war quasi als Gyra-Workflow abgebildet.
Und da gab es dann halt den Punkt irgendwann, bevor das Ding live gehen konnte, musste man eben diese Punkte abhaken.
Dokumentation und diese drei untergenannten Punkte, die mussten dann abgehakt werden.
So, und jetzt ratet mal, was die Leute gemacht haben.
Die haben beispielsweise im Confluence, das war das Wiki, der letzte Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe, verwendet hat.
Die haben dort für das Produkt eine leere Seite erstellt und haben ein Ticket aufgemacht, bitte Dokumentation erstellen.
Und an der Stelle haben sie das im Qualitygate abgehakt.
Weil Auftrag wurde erstellt und Seite wurde angelegt.
Natürlich waren diese Seiten oftmals komplett leer und niemals fertig, bis das Produkt wirklich live gegangen ist.
Was, wir haben nicht mehr Sus K. Akriege. Was ist da los, warum haben wir das nicht mehr?
Chatgy, wo ist Sus K. Akriege hin?
Warum ist das weg?
Ach, du siehst es?
Ich glaube, mein Browser ist einfach nur broken gerade.
Warte mal, Chat-Settings.
Ich glaube, mein Browser ist einfach nur broken.
So, und zumindest, das kam da halt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich jetzt darauf komme, das kam da öfters vor.
Ja, da wurden die Sachen immer abgehakt mit okay, aber da gingen trotzdem Services live, die keiner kannte.
Also, das ist natürlich ein Vorteil in dem neuen Laden, wo ich arbeite.
Die sind da zwar sehr bürokratisch und alles, aber zumindest das wird da garantiert nicht passieren.
Die sind so übertrieben bürokratisch, dass vielleicht ein Service drei Monate länger braucht.
Aber nicht, dass ihnen keiner, also nicht, dass die Sachen abgehakt sind.
Die sind halt so bürokratisch, pass mal auf, auch Fun-Fact.
Das ist natürlich, Finanzbranche und alles wird krass kontrolliert und sowas.
Ich habe letztens von einem gehört, also ab und zu werden dann halt auch mal Sachen überprüft und ob das okay ist.
Und letztens habe ich die Aussage von jemand gehört.
Also Max, so für die Anwendungsdokumentation, da können wir nicht nur fünf Seiten reinschreiben.
Das geht nicht, das nehmen die komplett auseinander bei der nächsten Kontrolle.
Aber was willst du denn machen? Kannst du jetzt nicht irgendwie Schriftgröße 24 machen, sodass es nachher mehr aussieht?
Und da hat er mir gesagt, na doch, ganz einfach, wir machen einfach ganz viele Auszüge von Firewall-Regeln und Systemen, also File-Systems und Systemkonfigurationen in diese Dokumentation rein.
Dann sind das am Ende dann 150 Seiten und das ist dann so viel, dass die sich das nicht mehr alles angucken können.
Und deswegen wird das bei der nächsten Überprüfung oder Kontrolle nicht auseinandergenommen.
Das ist also im Prinzip genauso, wie es nicht sein soll.
Es ist überall so, sobald es so komische Regeln gibt, gibt es die Ersten, die drauf rumtricksen.
Chetke, ich muss euch was fragen.
Pawschamp, MonkaSteer.
Nee, ich muss euch nichts fragen, ich muss euch was verraten.
Ich bin heute 37 Kilometer Fahrrad gefahren wieder und ich habe meine GoPro ans Fahrrad gemacht.
Das Problem ist, ich wollte das eigentlich für nichts verwenden.
Ich wollte einfach nur mal gucken, ob die Aufnahme läuft.
Also dementsprechend ist die Audioqualität kacke.
Es ist anstrengend, ich schniefe ein bisschen rum.
Aber dafür ist die Videoqualität ganz okay.
Wollen wir mal reingucken zusammen?
Aber ich warne euch gleich, ganz gucken können wir das nicht.
Das ist glaube ich insgesamt 35 Minuten lang oder so.
Ja, und ich liege mich am Anfang kurz.
Aber nicht komplett und ich glaube, das werde ich verschmerzen, weil ich liege eigentlich nur mein Bart.
Ich glaube, das ist vertretbar.
Die Fitness, was ist too much?
Dass ich im Stream erzähle, dass ich Fahrrad gefahren bin.
Too much? Ja, wir machen natürlich nur... Hä?
Wir machen doch fast nichts in der Richtung.
Man kann wirklich nichts aus dem Zoom-Chat kopieren?
Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, du kannst ganz normal Copy-Pasta machen.
Es geht halt um das, was mich gerade beschäftigt.
Was soll ich machen?
Wenn es nicht jedermanns Sache ist, was soll ich machen?
Schauen wir das Länderspiel zusammen an.
Das ist ein Länderspiel.
Ist das jetzt gerade Fußball oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Es interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Das wir es uns nicht anschauen können, das wissen wir alle, weil Copyright und so.
Aber es interessiert mich auch absolut gar nicht.
Residenz Sleeper.
Ne, es ist kein Lenovo. Weiß gar nicht, was das für eins ist.
Hat jemand ein bisschen Erfahrung mit Z-Scaler?
Wir wollen das ins Unternehmen aufnehmen.
Ich hatte vorher das...
Ja, ich habe das schon gesehen.
Es ist die Frage, warum ihr das machen wollt.
Ich habe das oftmals im Zusammenhang gesehen mit...
Man hat die doofe Idee und möchte SSL entschlüsseln am Ausgang.
Was ich echt für eine total bescheuerte Idee halte.
Weil das komplett entgegen dem Gedanken von SSL ist.
Von TLS.
Also in dem Umfeld habe ich das jetzt schon öfters gesehen.
Ich würde sowas einfach gar nicht machen.
Es ist doch so Scale-Kriegel.
Keine Ahnung, bei mir im Chat habe ich es vorher nicht gesehen.
Das war jetzt nicht bei uns das Einzige.
Hast du dir eine Brille zum Radeln gekauft?
Wie ist die?
Also ich finde die ganz gut.
Das ist so eine Brille, die automatisch aufgrund der Sonneneinstrahlung dunkler wird.
Oder halt auch heller, wenn weniger Sonneneinstrahlung ist.
Aber...
Also die ist schon okay.
Die ist ein bisschen zu klein, habe ich den Eindruck.
Von den Gläsern her.
Weil ganz vereinzelt kommt nochmal irgendwie eine Mücke rein.
Würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt so restlos empfehlen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll eine zu haben.
Weil ohne kann man nicht fahren, kriegt man laufend irgendwas ins Auge.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also du kannst das nur benutzen, das ist ja...
Du kannst das nur benutzen, wenn du...
...einer Custom-CA-Trust bist, der normalerweise nicht getrusted wird.
Anders funktioniert das nicht.
Sonst kann das ja nicht entschlüsseln.
Also ich finde Z-Scaler auch richtig Müll, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Wir wollen, dass die Nutzer dauerhaft in unserem Netzwerk bleiben und die Richtlinien nicht von zu Hause umgangen werden können.
Okay, dann verstehe ich nicht, was ihr genau machen wollt.
Aber ich meine, wenn das euer Anwendungszweck ist und Z-Scaler das Einzige ist, der das kann, warum nicht?
Ich verstehe es noch nicht so ganz.
Weil ich meine, die Leute wählen sich per VPN ein.
Und dann?
Das komme ich nicht ganz mit.
Magst du es mit Brille?
Ja, genau.
Ich mache kein Fahrrad-Review.
Welches Fahrrad ist es? Kannst du Ausrufezeichen Bike, Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad machen?
Ja, ich finde das richtig kacke.
Ich weiß nicht, warum da so viele Unternehmen drauf stehen.
Ob sie der Meinung sind, dass prinzipiell ihre Mitarbeiter alle Scammer sind, wo man auch jegliche Verschlüsselung aufbrechen muss dafür.
Ich weiß nicht, warum viele Unternehmen so ein großer Fan davon sind.
Das geht aber logischerweise nur auf Clients, die komplett vom Unternehmen kontrolliert werden, damit man eigenen CRs trusten kann.
Sonst klappt das mit dem Aufschlüssel nicht.
Und selbst dann müssen die Tools auf den jeweiligen Trust-Store zugreifen und sich daran halten.
Was auch nicht alle Tools machen.
Beispielsweise die Installer für das Google Cloud SDK machen das nicht.
Die gehen dann einfach nicht.
Okay, naja.
Ich halte davon nichts.
Ganz ehrlich, man muss doch nichts fixen, was nicht kaputt ist.
Ist der Bot gekaputt?
Bot gebroken? Kann das sein?
Ist der Nightbot kaputt?
Nightbot?
Ich glaube, der Nightbot ist kaputt.
Nightbot, was ist los?
Angeblich ist der Nightbot da.
Also laut dem Dashboard ist der Nightbot da.
Soll ich mal sagen Part-Channel und Joint-Channel?
Oder vergisst er dann die Commands?
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, wir müssen einfach warten, bis Nightbot sich von alleine fixt.
Bisher hat sich Nightbot immer von alleine gefixt.
Mir hat mal ein Netzwerker erzählt,
Moment, was?
Mir hat mal ein Netzwerker im Unternehmen erklärt,
dass HTTPS zu viel Traffic macht,
wenn wir es nicht ganz außen incepten.
Was?
Alter, was meinst du?
Das war doch ein Netzwerker nur auf dem Papier, oder?
Sicherlich ist Verschlüsseler-Traffic ein bisschen größer.
Es verursacht minimal mehr Traffic als nicht Verschlüsseler.
Aber es ist nicht so, als hätte man Bandbreitenprobleme dadurch.
Und es wird auch nicht weniger Traffic dadurch,
dass es intercepted wird.
Weil nach außen entsprechen die meisten Services eh nur noch HTTPS.
Versuch mal viele Websites,
die redirecten dich als erstes auf HTTPS.
Hä? Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Okay, machen wir nicht.
Ich weiß, es geht jetzt jeder auf Twitter und macht das wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich mach das nicht.
Ich hab mir das abgewöhnt, komische Sachen zu suchen.
Ich mach mal kurz ein Package-Update in der VRM.
Auf Twitter, oder auf X, wie man ja heutzutage sagen muss.
Weil da, also die letzten paar Monate,
wird da besonders großer Weird Champ hochgespült.
Habt ihr auf Twitter seit ein paar Wochen auch dieses nervige Ad
mit diesem Generate Your Anime Avatar
oder Generate Your AI Anime Waifu oder sowas?
Krieg ich immer als Empfehlung.
Direkt blockiert.
Das ist aber auch eine Sache,
die ich an Twitter jetzt echt nicht schlecht finde.
Dass bei Werbung,
wie heißt denn das,
so Hinweise, so unterstützende Sachen eingeplantet werden.
Zum Beispiel, wenn es mal wieder Pay-To-Win-Mobile-Shit gibt,
dann steht auf einmal drunter unter der Anzeige,
dieses Gameplay entspricht nicht dem Spiel und sowas.
User haben Kontext hinzugefügt und so.
Das finde ich nicht verkehrt auf Twitter mittlerweile.
Das gibt es auch noch nicht so lange.
Wie, warum kriegst du sowas nicht?
Ich krieg das laufend.
Ja, ja, ja, gleich, gleich, gleich.
Erst mal Package-Update machen.
File Arch, by the way.
Und Rolling Release.
Ach, Digital Ocean ist down.
Ja, dann.
Okay.
Was ist SFO3?
Das ist Kokona-Standort, oder?
San Francisco, aha.
Nicht, dass die da auch Brandwasser schaden.
Und Google hatte doch letztens in Merced so einfach alles, was es gab.
Überschwemmung.
Und dann irgendwie...
Elektronikprobleme und dann dadurch ein Brand oder so.
Rechts noch mal kurz ab.
So, noch mal kurz alles updaten.
Okay, so.
Ich sag euch, wir gucken nicht das komplette Video.
Könnt ihr mir aber mal sagen, wie die...
Also, ich weiß, dass die Audioqualität scheiße ist.
Das war auch nicht das Ziel des Ganzen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal die GoPro-Aufnahmequalität 1080p 60fps testen.
Und ich finde es ganz okay.
Allerdings werde ich wahrscheinlich auf 4K umschalten,
weil es doch noch ein bisschen crisper aussieht.
Auch downscaled.
So.
Blub, blub.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Connect to host.
Autoplay.
Was?
Okay, nice.
Also.
Können wir zusammengucken.
Guck mal hier.
Hab ich VLC drauf?
Ja, VLC auf jeden Fall.
Oh, müssen wir gleich mal updaten.
VLC.
So, was ist denn das erste Video?
Vermutlich...
Vermutlich das mit 1 vorne.
Guck mal.
Da ist er.
Fahrradstells.
Ich überspringe jetzt mal den Teil, in dem ich mich leake.
So.
Ich finde die Aufnahmequalität
ist wirklich ganz gut.
ASMR-Moaning.
Chat, gleich
mache ich euch
ASMR-Ear-Licking-Videos
an.
So, hier wird losgefahren.
Hier wird losgefahren.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das dröhnt aber ganz schön.
Ich muss mal kurz Tools, Effects...
Wir machen das jetzt so.
Wir machen jetzt das runter.
Weil das ist so Low-Frequency-Rauschen.
Äh.
Der Equalizer
funktioniert einfach gar nicht.
Hä?
Links geht links.
Doch,
funktioniert.
Zumindest mein Navi sagt links rum.
Also wie gesagt, Audioqualität
ist mega.
Windig.
So.
Also Audioqualität
ist halt mega kacke.
Aber ich finde,
Bildqualität geht voll in Ordnung, oder?
Ist die Kamera am Lenker?
Ja, ich habe so eine GoPro-Halterung.
Du kommentierst deine Fahrt.
Ich habe die Kamera angemacht,
ein bisschen dazu geschwätzt, ja.
Also ich finde die Qualität
für 1080p ist durchaus
okay.
Ich erwarte nicht, dass ihr versteht,
was ich sage.
Was ist eigentlich
mit dem Player gerade los?
Was ich für eine Navi-Software benutze?
Ich habe so
einen Garmin-Fahrradcomputer.
So.
Das ist, ehrlich gesagt, der erste
Part ist
übelst langweilig.
Das wäre besser, wenn man ein Stück
vom Lenker sieht.
Das ist schwierig.
Die GoPro hängt vorm Lenker.
Ansonsten müsste man die auf den Lenker machen.
Hast du ein E-Bike? Nein?
Ich bin am strampeln.
Man versteht
wirklich kaum was, ne?
Aber ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Da kommen die Leute
entgegen.
Irgendwann, ich muss euch
ein Part zeigen.
Ein Part ist tatsächlich ganz
witzig.
Ich glaube, das kommt im
zweiten.
Ich glaube,
das ist im zweiten drin.
Ich habe es nicht
hundertprozentig genau bestimmt.
Moment, Moment.
Fahrrad schaffe ich das meistens nicht.
Beim Rennen schon.
Ansehen, ihr Löcher.
Okay, jetzt klingt das mit dem
Equalizer deutlich besser, oder?
Es dröhnt viel weniger.
ASMR-Moaning-Sounds.
Das ist
flach, ja. Das geht direkt
an meinen lang.
MyCrew, der erwähne ich sogar hier
irgendwo im Hintergrund.
Ich muss euch
aber eine Sache
zeigen.
Wo ist es denn?
Oh mein Gott.
Hier.
Pass mal auf.
Irgendwo, das könnte hier sein.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Hier.
Der Tiefsthüpfel ist...
Ich wollte das Schild lesen,
als wäre ich fast gegen den Pfosten
gefahren.
Das könnte hier sein, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Wo kannst
dir...
Der Tiefsthüpfel ist...
Wo kannst dir...
Man sollte keine Schilder lesen
und gegenüber die Pfosten fahren.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das hier war.
Ich konnte es nicht genau lesen.
Vielleicht kommt es auch noch.
Weil wenn ich es weiter gelesen hätte, wäre ich
gegen den Kackpfosten gefahren.
Wo kannst dir...
Wie ich einfach
Kackweight beim Fahrradfahren sage.
Nein.
Ich habe extra ein bisschen geschwätzt
beim Aufnehmen.
Ein bisschen Gas geben.
Und es geht sogar noch ein bisschen besser.
Ey, der Weg, der war so übertrieben
holprig.
Wo kannst dir...
Gib ihm...
Da dreht er rein, da dreht er rein.
Der Weg, man.
Guck mal, was für Schlaglöcher
in der Straße sind, man.
Das geht mal.
Auf die Beine
und auf die Hände.
So, hier
müssen wir jetzt gerade
aus...
Wir sind jetzt in
Großkronzenburg.
So geht das.
Und hier
mache ich auch
Monca 3head.
Ach ne, hier kontrolliere ich erst nochmal die Kamera.
Und hier
bin ich auch ein bisschen zu dumm noch.
Hier verfahre ich mich jetzt.
Moment.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es hier lang geht.
Leute.
Ich drehe mal um.
Jetzt hochschalten.
Übrigens, elektronische Schaltung.
Mega, mega nice.
Wie lang geht es?
Habt ihr es gehört?
Ich drehe mal um.
Hier.
Jetzt hochschalten.
Ja, da ging es nicht weiter.
Kurz im Kreis.
Ich glaube ich...
Aber ohne Mist.
Die Videoqualität
von der Kamera ist gar nicht mal
schlecht, oder? Ich meine, das ist der
Low-Quality 1080p
Modus, wo die Kamera angeblich
über zwei Stunden hält in Daueraufnahmen.
Kann man doch eigentlich nichts sagen.
Geht doch vollkommen in Ordnung, oder?
Geht vollkommen in Ordnung, ja.
Und ich meine, am Ende...
Irgendwo fahre ich hier noch
ein bisschen durch die Stadt.
Und...
Hier fahre ich nochmal
die Brücke hoch.
Stabilisator?
Nein, das ist ganz normales GoPro.
Ich habe das einfach
dran. Ich meine, ich bin kein
Fitness-Vlogger und ich habe da
keine große Ahnung bis jetzt von
Kamera-Equipment irgendwie fürs Fahrrad.
Ich habe einfach meine Kamera halt dran gehängt.
Jetzt habe ich das mit dem Bike-Router
erzählt gerade.
Da steht halt bei mir nichts.
Aber dann habe ich gefunden,
das Komod
auf entweder
die...
Hier geht es ein bisschen
Brücke hoch.
Da musste ich ganz schön schnaufen hier die Brücke
nochmal rauf.
Und jetzt geht erstmal
zackig den Berg runter.
Ich fahre über die Brücke.
Linksrum.
Noch ein Stück am Eingang.
Noch ein Stückchen weiter.
Das zeige ich euch aber nicht so genau.
Ich will ja nicht im Schatten
meine Straße lücken oder sowas.
Jetzt geht es aber ordentlich bergab.
Jetzt wird aber reingetreten.
Ich hoffe, hier sind keine Schlagflächen.
Wenn hier Schlagflächen sind, bin ich gefickt.
Und was ihr nicht gesehen habt,
ich wäre einmal fast aufs Maul gefallen,
weil ich über einen Ast gefahren bin.
Wir schauen gerade mein GoPro-Footage von heute an.
Aber nicht wirklich anschauen.
Wir haben jetzt 5 Minuten oder so geguckt.
Ja, sieht gerade gut aus.
36, 37 kmh.
Für mich ist das übelst schnell.
Ja, ist es auch.
Ich glaube, für Leute,
die öfters Fahrrad fahren,
37 kmh auch nichts.
Kann es sein, dass du den Lenker zu sehr umklammerst?
Siehst du das?
Du siehst meine Hände gar nicht.
Vielleicht ist das so.
Eigentlich halte ich gar nicht so fest.
Ich drücke manchmal ein bisschen zu fest drauf.
Oh, da rechts.
Weil das ist eine Ampel,
da darf man drüber fahren mit dem Fahrrad.
Und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht,
ich fahre möglichst langsam,
dass ich noch über die Ampel drüber komme.
Aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Da hört man die Schaltung.
Die Oma hier hätte auch nicht gedacht,
dass sie heute Abend mal auf Twitch ist.
So, jetzt ist es fertig.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Kannst du zurückspulen.
Das ist hinter Großkotzenburg gewesen.
Kannst suchen, wenn du es wissen willst.
Ja, so sah das.
Ich sage es eigentlich noch im Video,
dass die Leute eigentlich gar nicht anfangen müssen,
Witze drüber zu machen.
Was meinst du, wofür brauchst du mehr Kalorien?
Beim Laufen.
Aber Fahrradfahren geht länger als Laufen.
Insgesamt beim Radeln
auf gleiche Zeit beim Laufen.
So.
Was macht eigentlich DigitalOcean?
Ist MonkaSteer beendet?
Ne.
Eine Rose Blackroad.
Äh, Backroad, nicht Blackroad.
Backroad.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
So, was können wir uns denn heute mal
auf YouTube zu Gemüte führen?
Das machen wir erstmal zu.
Das war Amazon Prime Day.
Habt ihr irgendwas beim Prime Day gekauft?
Also ich habe letztendlich eine Sache bestellt.
Aber ansonsten war nichts dabei.
Und ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau,
was von den Sachen, die ich bestellt habe,
jetzt genau beim Prime Day dabei war.
Also,
ich bin ja hier so ungefähr
470 Meter hohen Berg,
das ist der höchste, den wir haben, hochgefahren.
Und da runter hatte ich echt so ein bisschen Schiss.
Das war zwar nicht 70,
aber das war noch mal deutlich schneller als 37.
Da hatte ich schon ein bisschen Schiss.
Da habe ich auch ein bisschen viel gebremst.
Scheibenbremsen mögen das ja eigentlich nicht so,
wenn man die zu oft benutzt und zu lange am Stück.
Aber da habe ich mir nicht getraut.
Ein Rasierer, okay.
Neuen Schreibtisch.
Ich glaube, ich habe den Packen Batterien
bestellt beim Prime Day.
Das war's. Es ist eigentlich nur Schrott dabei gewesen.
Gibt es denn irgendwas,
was wir hier...
Das ist auch mal zu.
Irgendwas, was wir uns auf YouTube noch angucken können.
Ihr wisst ja, morgen früh wieder,
ganz normal wie gehabt,
ein einfacher Stream.
Battlefield 2042.
Ach, sag mal,
wo wir gerade dabei sind,
wie sieht es da eigentlich mit Season 6 aus?
Sollte die jetzt nicht irgendwann starten?
Oder ist das gestartet schon?
Man hört ja nichts mehr von dem Game.
Ich meine, zu Recht, aber...
Ist schon gestartet.
Ich meine, wisst ihr, was bei solchen
Blogposts immer mega nice wäre?
Datum! Ich ignoriere prinzipiell
auch alle Posts, die man
irgendwo verlinkt bekommt, ohne Datum.
Das nervt mich immer, wenn ich weiß, was Sache ist.
Was gibt es denn?
Was gibt es denn da Neues? Lohnt es sich überhaupt?
Season 6
Dark Creations.
Eine neue Map. Redacted.
Hä? Gab es die nicht
das letzte Mal schon? Oder gibt es eine Map,
die so ähnlich heißt?
Neue Waffen, Ammo
und Medical Pouches.
Stimmt, das gab es bisher nicht.
Es gab keine
Taschen zum Aufheben.
Ein neues
Vehikel. Also haben wir jetzt insgesamt
5 oder so.
Aim Assist Improvements for
Controllers.
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Es startet am 10.
Ach, das ist schon seit 4 Tagen live?
Ach ja.
Ist das quasi
Ghost of Wish bestellt?
Die Map ist
inspiert bei Locker und Operation Metro.
Ich weiß, dass
Locker und Metro
mega beliebte Maps waren. Ich muss sagen,
mir war sowohl Locker
als auch vor allem Metro
dann auch ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Metro ist eine coole Map.
Vor allem, wenn man sie
über die komplette
Länge mal spielt.
Also quasi auch nicht nur
Domination und dann quasi immer
um die Flagge in der Mitte kloppen.
Sondern wenn man wirklich mal die komplette Länge
auch mal mit Rush zum Beispiel spielt.
Also quasi den Vorplatz, die Metro.
Dann die nächsten Metro M-Comps raus
und dann hinten raus aus der Metro.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe Metro
einfach zu Tode
gespielt irgendwie schon.
Und Locker
ist im Prinzip der Metro-Abklatscher
aus BF4. Also ich weiß nicht.
Aber es ist nicht verkehrt,
wenn sie Maps nehmen.
Ich will mich jetzt ja nicht beschweren, wenn sie mal was machen,
was wahrscheinlich gut ankommt.
Weil das restliche Spiel besteht zum größten Teil
aus Sachen, die nicht gut ankommen.
Moment, wie jetzt?
AMD-Updates führen zu einem
Bann in CS?
Ja, dass da irgendein Anti-Cheating
anschlagen kann, hätte man sich ja auch denken können
bei AMD, oder?
Übrigens, das ist, habe ich mir sagen lassen,
eines der Gründe,
warum das, ah ich kann es euch jetzt nicht
zeigen, weil ich es hier irgendwie für den
Streaming-Account aushabe,
warum das NVIDIA
GeForce
Overlay, dort wo man
auch Shadowplay und sowas einstellen kann,
ich meine das hier.
Das Ding hier, was da aufploppt,
wenn man ALT-Z
normalerweise drückt, ja, das hier meine ich.
Das Ding hier.
Ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass dieses Ding
relativ beliebt wäre,
für Cheats
zu hijacken, weil
das quasi von jedem
Game und jeder
Anti-Cheat-Engine
irgendwie whitelisted ist,
weil es halt Bestandteil vom
NVIDIA-Treiber ist.
Und auch FPS-injected und sonst was.
Dass das sehr beliebt ist
dafür,
für Cheats sich da reinzuhängen.
Das heißt, wenn man Anti-Lag-Enabled,
kann es sein, dass man weg-banned wird.
Ist CS2
eigentlich Free-to-Play?
Ich habe mich null damit beschäftigt.
Oder muss man das kaufen?
Ich tippe darauf, dass man es kaufen muss.
Zumindest initial.
Aber ich wissen, tue ich es nicht.
Wisst ihr das?
Ja, ist auch gut so.
Ist Free-to-Play, okay.
Prime sollte man sich kaufen, sonst unspielbar.
Echt? Warum? Was sind da für Einschränkungen?
Kannst du zum Beispiel nur
ein Match am Tag spielen oder wie?
So, lass uns mal kurz das eine
fertig schauen.
Was da jetzt noch Neues reingekommen ist.
Also.
Neue Map. Okay.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt immer noch weniger Maps
als...
Na, nicht als Battlefield 3 zu Release, aber
auf jeden Fall deutlich
weniger Maps als Battlefield 3
mit DLCs. Achso.
Das sind Areale
aus der
aus der Map. Container!
Hättet ihr gedacht, dass die Map
wieder Container beinhaltet? Ich nicht.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
Container gibt es in dem Spiel nicht.
Endlich Container.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Das hier sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen aus wie eine
BC2 Map.
Wie hieß Laguna
Bresa oder so. Gab es doch eine Map
in BC2. Das sieht tatsächlich
Dschungel-mäßig ein bisschen so aus.
Mit diesem komischen Schild hier oben außen vor.
Stress?
Das ist was?
Ja, ich mein, du siehst
schon mal, es ist wenig zu bieten, wenn
irgendwie die Hälfte
der Post aus ein paar Screenshots von der neuen Map
besteht.
Kaputtes Schiff, das brauche ich unbedingt.
Gibt es noch nicht genug.
Okay, es gibt einen Assault Rifle.
Es gibt einen DMR, es gibt eine Pistole
und es gibt
noch einen Assault Rifle. Ja, gut.
Okay.
Das finde ich nice, dass es Ammo und Medical
so
Taschen gibt.
Kann man dann aufheben und
mal gucken, ob die funktionieren
wie ein BF4, dass man die aufhebt und wird dann
Heal-Over-Time-mäßig geheilt.
Es gibt eine Drohne
oder ein
Flugmotorrad
oder sowas.
Wenigstens mal was, was ins Setting
von dem Game passt.
Ja, das ist echt Ghost
of Wish bestellt.
Reconbalancing.
Ja, genau. Wir haben unbedingt
noch mehr
Leute, die auf der Map markiert werden, gebraucht.
Sagt mal,
meine blöde Frage,
die haben letzten
Patch oder sagen wir mal
letzte Season,
angekündigt, sie wollen
das Waffenverhalten
aller Waffenkategorien
reworken. Und sie machen
das nicht alles auf einmal, sondern
fangen mit Assault Rifles an.
Und seit der letzten Season konntest du ja erstmal
Assault Rifles gar nicht mehr richtig spielen.
Es sei denn, du hast dich halt
auf die neue Sache eingestellt, was
durchaus okay war, aber halt
fragwürdig, weil es die anderen Waffen nicht haben.
Was ist denn daraus jetzt geworden?
Wie sieht es denn mit den
Reworks aus für die anderen Waffenkategorien?
Haben die das einfach wieder vergessen?
Oder bin ich einfach dem Spiel nicht genug
gefolgt, als ich mitbekommen habe?
Haben die einfach gesagt, jebaited, wir
machen jetzt einen Rework und machen
dann doch keinen Rework, oder?
Ach hier, LMG Balance Update.
Naja.
Okay, ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube,
wenn wir, hab ich das noch installiert?
Ich hab's noch installiert. Okay, heute
nicht, aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen, vielleicht gucken wir morgen Nachmittag mal rein.
Weil die Season
ist, wenn die, seit 10.
ist die raus, das ist mitten in der Woche.
Das heißt, dieses Wochenende werden diese
Season die meisten Leute spielen. Das heißt,
wenn man nochmal reingucken will,
dann ist wahrscheinlich dieses Wochenende,
dieses und nächstes Wochenende das Beste.
Dann rennen die Leute ja wieder weg.
Guck mal mal.
Steam Stats, BF2042.
Ja.
Wow!
Haben die alle so viel, zu viel Zeit, oder was?
War da Free Weekend
oder irgendwas? Hab ich da was verpasst?
So viele sind ja noch nie
zu der neuen Season an Start gekommen.
Ha!
Ich will mich nicht beschweren, dass Leute
da sind und wahrscheinlich ist es zwei
Wochen später auch wieder im Keller mit 7000
Spielern. Lass uns mal eine Sache
vergleichen.
Äh.
Battlefield V, man, hat einfach viermal
so viele Spieler. Ne, ja,
viermal so viele Spieler
wie 2042 im Durchschnitt.
Battlefield I
hat dreimal so viele.
Okay, ja, dann, dann
erklärt's das natürlich.
Warum da alle so traurig, auf einmal,
ja, okay.
Ne, ist es auch nicht.
Ich glaub, ich guck morgen mal wieder rein.
Einfach mal, ich hätt mal echt
wieder Bock auf ein, zwei Runden Battlefield.
Da müsst ihr euch aber erstmal
wieder dran gewöhnen, weil ich hab jetzt die letzten paar
Monate kaum irgendwelche
Eco-Shooter-Sachen gespielt. Also, so die
ersten drei, vier Runden sind wieder ultra
PPGAIM, danach geht's ja meistens.
Danach wird wieder gebashed.
Ich frag mich manchmal,
es soll jetzt nicht überheblich klingen,
ja, auch wenn jetzt irgendjemand gleich...
Ich frag mich aber oftmals, wie
schlecht eigentlich Leute immer noch
2023 in Games so sein können.
Ich spiele eigentlich so gut wie nix
an Shootern, außer ab und zu mal ein bisschen
Battlefield in letzter Zeit. Und
trotzdem, ich sacke die ersten zwei, drei Runden rein
und dann bin ich eigentlich konstant
Top 3 durchgängig.
Wo man sich so denkt, ey, das kann doch
nicht sein. Man muss doch, man muss
doch, ey,
das geht doch nicht.
Aber ich will mich nicht beschweren, weil
dann kann man wenigstens ein bisschen ordentlich was
killen. Und nachdem ich das jetzt gesagt
hab, werd ich wahrscheinlich ab morgen komplett reinschweißen.
MW3-Beta
juckt, ja, ganz ehrlich,
mich juckt
die MW3-Beta gar nicht.
Weil,
ich fand die MW1 vom
Multiplayer her extrem
anstrengend. Ich meine jetzt nicht Warzone,
sondern den normalen Multiplayer.
Extrem anstrengend
und
was ist denn das beste Wort, um das zu
beschreiben? Extrem
anstrengend,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen verschwitzt
und tryhard, das ist nicht zwangsläufig
das Problem. Jede Overwatch-Ranked-Runde
ist auch verschwitzt und tryhard.
Enorm
passiv
trifft's glaube ich ganz gut.
MW1 und MW2,
also die Remakes.
Die meisten Leute sind da so
übelst über die Map
gestelzt, haben
haben dann irgendwo in der Ecke
gewartet und haben dann da rum geaimt
den ganzen Tag, anstatt sich
einfach mal ein bisschen zu bewegen.
Ich kann es ja gar nicht übel nehmen, das funktioniert
ja wunderbar in dem Game.
Aber ich finde den ganzen
Multiplayer einfach nicht schön
spielbar. MW1, MW2
und MW3 wird genau in das
gleiche Horn blasen, da werden es die
paar Map-Remakes aus dem Original MW2
auch nicht rausreißen.
Und
Skill-Based Matchmaking tut sein Rest.
Ist das wirklich, ist das
bestätigt?
Oder ist das wieder irgendeine Legend, die
im Umlauf ist?
Was ist das denn?
iPhone 15 Pro Max.
Also ich habe ein iPhone 14
Pro, das
reicht und ich sehe nicht ein, mir
ein iPhone 15 Pro zu kaufen.
Einfach random jetzt.
Man ist so scharf
drauf, random 1300 Euro auszugeben
und 1400 Euro ausgeben bin ich auch nicht.
Und was schreibt die GameStar?
Achso, du meinst jetzt,
dass es eigentlich ein DLC werden sollte.
Man sieht das glaube ich auch in Steam.
In Steam habe ich einen Screenshot gesehen,
dass irgendjemand gesagt hat,
die MW3-Beta wäre
als DLC für MW2
gelistet in Steam.
Der Action-Button ist tatsächlich das einzige,
was ich auch gerne am iPhone 14 hätte.
Aber
dafür kaufe ich trotzdem kein neues iPhone.
Okay, dann zeig doch mal her.
Dann zeig doch mal her.
Warum sollte man sich das kaufen?
Mit USB-C,
weil sie dazu gezwungen werden.
Ich nicht. Ich kaufe die Pro-Version,
aber nicht die Pro Max, weil die Pro Max
ist mir zu groß.
Ich komme jetzt schon kaum mit dem Daumen
von unten oben hin,
ohne dass ich das Handy ein bisschen durch die Hand rutschen
lassen muss. Und das Pro Max ist
mir dann einfach zu groß.
Übrigens, ich muss euch noch was zeigen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Da habe ich mich ja heute schon
auf Twitter drüber aufgeregt, aber
nicht Nutter.
Wo habe ich es denn? Alter!
Kann ich es mal ordentlich schreiben?
Twitter kann man ja nicht mal aufmachen direkt,
weil es nervt.
Wisst ihr, ich benutze
doch in fast
jedem Browser
Return YouTube Dislikes.
Das ist eine
Chrome-Extension.
Die seht ihr ja auch hier.
Das ist eine Chrome-Extension, die ich
hier aus irgendwelchen...
Ah, ich habe die einfach nur nicht gepinnt.
Die ich immer anhabe und die
zeigt einem die Dislikes auf einem YouTube-Video an.
So, das ist eigentlich
ganz praktisch.
Diese Extension ist, wie ihr ja auch seht,
kaputt seit 1-2 Tagen.
Und da gibt es auch schon ein GitHub-Issue
für.
Da gibt es
ein paar Comments drin.
Die finde ich echt richtig beschissen.
Also das erste muss man
erstmal sagen, Hut ab! Issue erstellt,
der Maintainer sagt,
er macht ein Update,
er kümmert sich drum,
working on a fix, all will be good soon.
Also da muss man wirklich mal sagen, der ist da wirklich
sehr, sehr zackig am Start.
Ist auch ein sehr beliebtes Projekt.
So, jetzt diskutieren die Leute ein bisschen rum,
bla bla, und irgendwann sagt
er hier,
fix is submitted for review
to all stores. Damit sollte
die Sache eigentlich erstmal gegessen sein.
Das dauert
ja immer ein paar Tage.
Je nachdem, wie sehr
YouTube oder die
Appstore-Betreiber darauf Bock haben.
Also da muss man, also man kann dem wirklich
nichts sagen. Die haben das hier gemeldet,
7.57 Uhr
und er hat ein fix zum Appstore
um
10.51 Uhr,
PM, AM, Sekunde,
Cocona-Time, shit.
Nee, guck mal da, zweieinhalb Stunden
später hat er das committed.
Also wirklich, was willst du
mehr? Zweieinhalb Stunden später
ist das gefixt gewesen.
Kannst du wirklich nichts sagen, oder?
Gut.
Jetzt kommen ein paar Leute und sagen,
oh, ich hab das gleiche Problem, ja,
so und hier und Restall, bla bla,
bla bla, wir wissen es alle schon.
So mal,
latest fix has been submitted, so,
noch mal zur Erinnerung, bla bla bla,
bla bla bla, so, so.
Und dann,
und dann kommt irgendwann der Dude.
Guckt euch das mal
an, Alter.
Was ist mit den Leuten verkehrt?
Seriously.
Das ist ein komplett
kostenloses Open-Source-Projekt,
was Sachen auf YouTube
wieder gerade biegt,
auf die YouTube-
Google kein Bock hat.
Das kostet nix.
Der Typ macht das in seiner Freizeit.
Der hat nach zweieinhalb Stunden
den Fix committed.
Und dann kommt er hier an.
Timeframe would be nice.
And good customer service.
Als hat er eben einen Support-Vertrag
gekauft bei dem Kerl.
Instead of,
we just have to wait.
Der hat das für den App-Store submitted
und das dauert halt zwei Tage, bis die das
reviewed haben, da kann er nix dafür.
So.
Come on.
Now.
Lach meinen Arsch auf.
It's
and you are slacking on an
extension. Still not working
and it's blah blah blah, what's taking so long?
Also entweder ist das der Ultratroll
oder es ist einfach nur komplett
nerviger Spast, man. So, Leute,
fucken mich ultra. Ich muss grad mal, wenn ich
grad schon ein bisschen am Aufgeregen bin,
muss mal kurz gucken, ob der Fiat Champ neue
Tickets hat.
Oh shit.
What?
Ja, er hat zu oft
refreshed.
Er hat den Refresh-Timer zu hoch gestellt.
Ja, guck mal. Er hat den Refresh-Timer
irgendwie auf eine Sekunde oder so gestellt.
Keine Ahnung. Won't fix.
Also, ich find die Leute.
Nee, das ist nicht wayne.
Versetzt dich mal in die Rolle
rein, dasjenigen, dem
das Repo gehört.
Solche Comments sind einfach kacke.
Warum bist du beim Fiat Champ am slacken?
Ja, das kann nicht sein, 2023.
Just
Home Assistant add-on.
All slacking here.
Das ist wirklich echt, was mit denen los ist.
Customer support.
Ja, nicht genug Downvotes.
Es gibt genug Leute,
die sehen das eh nicht.
Ich mein, ich kenn das.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die mich nerven.
An Open-Source-Produkten
und Projekten.
Gibt's
genug Sachen.
Ich überleg grad,
was ist so ein typisches Ding,
was mich nervt.
Mir fällt jetzt spontan keins ein,
aber ich weiß, es gibt genug,
die mich übelst
nerven, immer wieder.
Keine Ahnung.
Mir fällt grad nix ein.
Was?
Vodafone.
Oh, es hat grad geleckt.
Ein bisschen, wie es aussieht.
Aber jetzt ist es jetzt wieder gut.
Jetzt ist es wieder gut.
Ja, also wie gesagt, es gibt auch da Sachen,
die mich bei Open-Source-Projekten aufregen.
Gerade, doch, mir fällt eine Sache
auf. Also eine Sache, die mich bei
Open-Source-Projekten nervt, auf GitHub ist,
das seh ich bei Kubernetes
beispielsweise total oft, kennt ihr
diese Projekte, die
Tickets automatisch nach 30 Tagen
schließen, obwohl das nach wie vor akut
ist und kaputt ist und scheiße ist.
Und da kommt dann irgendein Bot,
Ticket is stale,
wird geclosed.
Und dann musst du reinposten,
not stale. Und je nach
Projekt wirst du dann angeschissen,
dass du nicht dein
Issue pushen sollst.
Also, das nervt
aber trotzdem.
Das ist so ein Ein-Mann-Projekt
hier. Also der Typ hat mich aufgeregt.
Jetzt regen
sich noch ein bisschen drüber auf hier.
Das wird noch richtig abfucken
hier.
Ad-Blockers violate YouTube Terms of Service.
Das wird
noch richtig abfucken, sag ich euch.
noch mehr
Wettrennen zwischen Ad-Werbe-Blockern
und das fuckt halt richtig ab.
Ich mein,
ich kann sagen, stört mich nicht, ich hab YouTube Premium,
ich seh eh keine Werbung. Aber bald,
was wird als nächstes kommen?
Als nächstes kommt, ach ja, YouTube Premium,
die müssen sich halt nur ein bisschen weniger Werbung
angucken. Aber es gibt trotzdem Werbung.
Hast du übrigens die Artikel
von Heise schon gesehen, wonach Microsoft
anscheinend mehr mit dem Linux-Körnle romantisiert.
Die haben angeblich schon
Installationsanweisungen für die Linux-Districts
rausgehauen. Hä, wie, Installationsanweisungen?
Intern
bei sich, oder was?
Ja, kann ich auch verstehen.
Ich würd auch, wenn es möglich wäre,
alles nur noch mit Linux machen.
Windows ist halt der komplette Abfuck.
Das Ding ist halt das, ich benutze
Windows für die Sachen, wo Windows taugt.
Ja, zum Beispiel
Sachen spielen,
oder hier auch live streamen, wobei das auch unter
Linux gehen würde, wenn alles andere geht.
Auch mal ein ganzes Videozeug machen.
Ach, ist es jetzt endlich durch, ja?
Haben sie es jetzt geschafft?
Hab ich gar nicht, hab ich gar nicht gelesen.
Gab es da einen Artikel dazu?
Activision.
Ach, hier!
Activision Blizzard gehört jetzt zu Microsoft.
Haben sie es endlich geschafft.
Das heißt, Bobby
kriegt jetzt eine fette Ablösung.
Oder eine Ablöse nennt man das ja nicht.
Äh, tja, wie heißt denn das?
Schmerzensgeld, oder?
Nee, wie nennt man das in dem, in dem
Abfindung, hä?
Und dann ist er
weg.
Und freut sich in Ast.
Sony war gegen den Deal, ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Oh, ja!
Oh, nee, please, nein!
No!
No, god, please, no!
Demnächst brauchst du dann einen Blizzard-Account, um dich
in Windows einzuloggen.
Auf der anderen Seite,
vielleicht kann man sich dann wirklich mit seinem Blizzard-Account
in Windows einloggen.
Und Microsoft denn wirklich?
Ja, gut,
das ist für ihre Azure-Sachen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
hauptsächlich für alle, die das dann auch in Azure
benutzen wollen, ja.
Wird da Arch-Linux erwähnt?
Ah!
Okay, legit Anleitung.
Linux
ohne Arch, Anleitung ohne Arch-Linux
wär nicht legit, aber jetzt ist es approved.
Jetzt, jetzt ist es
approved.
Please allow me to interject for a moment.
Ja, siehste?
Ich versteh das!
Ganz ehrlich, es macht für Microsoft
gar nicht mehr so viel Sinn in der heutigen Zeit,
anti-Linux zu sein, weil
das meiste Geld verdient Microsoft
mit Cloud
und ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
aber wahrscheinlich mit Cloud und
Cloud-Services,
einmal Azure und halt auch
Office und das ganze
Ökosystem da drumherum.
Und umso mehr Windows
sagen wir mal zu irgendwie so
einem
fünften Rad wird
oder immer
unbedeutender wird, umso
weniger Sinn macht das für Microsoft irgendwie
anti-Linux zu sein.
Allerdings, und das ist halt bei Microsoft so,
Microsoft selbst gibt es ja
gar nicht. Microsoft selbst
besteht aus ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Abteilungen,
die sich zum größten Teil
untereinander nicht abkönnen. Und die werden
im Zweifeltun irgendwie ein bisschen von
der bisschen Macht, die sie haben
irgendwie abgeben.
Das heißt, es wird weiter so laufen wie bisher.
Ey!
Der Nightbot funktioniert wieder!
Pog! Jay, danke schon für den Sub!
Chris, danke für den Sub,
hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Pog! Ja, ich weiß,
ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber für alle, die wissen wollen, was ich für ein Fahrrad hab,
das da. Microsoft macht
durchaus sinnvolle Sachen. Microsoft
macht genauso viel Zeug, die mir auf den Sack geht, aber
Microsoft hat, gerade
wenn man sich anguckt, was bei GitHub läuft,
ich muss sagen, ich finde nicht, dass
GitHub seit der Übernahme schlechter geworden ist.
Ich muss aber auch sagen,
nehmen wir mal
drei Sachen, ja? Nehmen wir mal Twitch,
äh, Twitter
und GitHub.
Also, ich finde, GitHub
ist nicht wirklich schlechter geworden
seit der Übernahme.
Man könnte sogar sagen, es ist sehr viel
Neues passiert, von
Copilot angefangen
bis, ähm, ja, was denn sonst noch?
Sicherlich einiges,
was mir jetzt nicht einfällt. Insgesamt
muss ich sagen, ist GitHub vielleicht
sogar ein Tick besser geworden, seitdem das
bei Microsoft ist.
Bei Twitter muss ich sagen,
ich war am Anfang,
es ist nicht so, dass ich jemandem sag, ey, guck mal,
das muss jetzt scheiße werden, weil Elon
das übernommen hat und so, da gab's ja ganz viele
Ultra-Hater am Anfang.
Ich war da am Anfang der Sache gar nicht so
komplett
abgeneigt,
weil manche Sachen klangen
gar nicht mal so verkehrt,
wie zum Beispiel, dass es einen ordentlichen,
nachvollziehbaren Verifizierungsprozess
geben soll und sowas fand ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Mittlerweile muss ich allerdings sagen,
viele Sachen auf Twitter sind einfach nur
absolut pippiger und dämlich, ja?
Also das Letzte,
was mir auch so ein bisschen komplett den Spaß
versaut hat an X,
ist ja nicht mal Twitter, ist das mit
Einlog-Zwang und das, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist,
man Profile nicht mal richtig angucken kann
und solche Geschichten, also, dann war's
echt vorbei. So, und dann,
äh, was wollte ich jetzt
als Drittes noch, Leute, was hab ich gesagt?
GitHub?
Ach, Twitch, Twitch, Twitch.
Twitch ist so ein Ding, seit
Amazon da am Start ist,
also viele sind sich ja ultra am Beschweren
über Twitch.
Und ich finde, es gibt auch viele Kritikpunkte auf Twitch,
gerade, also, mein Hauptkritikpunkt wäre,
wenn es, wenn es
um Twitch geht, aber das war ein Problem, was
Twitch schon immer hatte,
ist die Auslegung, sag mal, die sehr
große Range,
wie die
Regeln ausgelegt werden auf Twitch
und dass
eigentlich das sehr offen,
sag mal, so einen sehr großen
Interpretationsspielraum hat,
Twitch-Regeln.
Und das war irgendwie schon immer ein Problem,
das Twitch hatte, und ich finde, das ist die letzten Jahre nicht unbedingt
besser geworden. Ansonsten
finde ich, ist Twitch
auch nicht, zumindest aus
technischer Sicht und alles,
nicht schlechter geworden durch Amazon, eher besser.
Findest du? Die hatten früher auch schon
übelste Probleme. Und Twitch ist
beispielsweise sogar stabiler geworden, seit's bei Amazon
ist. Gefühlt. Ich kenn keine
Statistik. Aber Twitch hatte früher
total oft Probleme, und mittlerweile
haben sie auch Abosuma-Probleme,
aber sie haben heute im Vergleich zu
früher noch mal ein vielfaches mehr,
quasi richtig große Streams, teilweise
mit zehntausenden Zusätzen. Das gab's ja
früher kaum. Was?
Electron sucks? Also,
ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht,
Chatge, aber ich finde,
von allen Electron-Anwendungen
fühlt sich
Visual Studio Code noch mit am
knackigsten und schnellsten
an. Oder?
Also ja, man merkt es,
dass Visual Studio Code unter der
Haube nur ein Browser ist.
Aber wenn man früher Atom verwendet hat,
zum Beispiel, von Github,
die quasi ja der Erfinder
von Electron sind, darf man nicht vergessen.
Also, Electron ging ja
hervor aus
Atom. Das war in dem Fall von
Github ein Editor.
Ursprünglich hieß
Electron auch nicht Elektron, sondern
Atom Shell.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Schau was uns...
Ja, das stimmt,
das hat Microsoft komplett
verkackt.
Und dieser komische
Nokia-Deal, der war nun wirklich
für beide Seiten
eher nix.
Am Ende sind sie vielleicht noch ein paar
Patente gekommen von Nokia,
aber wirklich gebracht hat's
ihnen nix. Das hab ich schon
mal irgendwo gesehen.
Wusstet ihr, dass Office 365 zum größten Teil
eine React-Anwendung ist?
Also könnte man jetzt quasi sagen,
Microsoft verwendet im großen Stil
eine Technologie von
Facebook, was ich aber
nachvollziehen kann. Ich mein, dafür findest du
Entwickler, das ist verbreitet, hat ein großes Ökosystem
und ist genau für sowas gedacht.
Ja.
Du hast komplett recht,
das wäre wirklich
für alle, die in diesem Microsoft-Ökosystem
mit AD und sowas leben, gar nicht schlecht.
Heute hast du so halbgares Mobile-Device-Management.
Mit
mit
halbgaren Lösungen.
Also mir fällt von Facebook, ich weiß,
die haben noch viel mehr, die haben beispielsweise auch
relativ viel C++
Sachen open-sourced,
aber mir fällt von Facebook spontan,
wenn du mich fragen würdest, was gibt's von Facebook
open-sourced, mir würde erst einmal
instant nur React
einfallen und da müsste ich ein bisschen nachdenken.
Wie gesagt, die haben irgendwie ein bisschen
C++-Zeug noch open-sourced,
die haben
haben die nicht irgendwie ihr komisches
PHP-Zeug auch noch?
Lama, korrekt, das ist jetzt
neu, war CraftQL, CraftQL,
du hast recht, hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht,
ja klar, war ja auch von Facebook.
Ja, siehste?
Aber das Erste, was mir einfallen würde, ist
eindeutig React.
Erinnert sich noch einer an
Twitter Bootstrap,
was ja heute gar nichts mehr mit Twitter zu tun
hat, wahrscheinlich auch
nichts Besseren dafür.
Kann schon sein, ich mein,
es wird wahrscheinlich Teile benutzen,
die open-sourced sind.
Ja, okay, siehste, hab ich mich
nicht mit beschäftigt. Ich wollte
übrigens mein
OS updaten
und hab das komplett vergessen.
Machen wir mal Update, Reboot,
Arch, by the way,
use ich,
nur mal angemerkt,
damit ihr das auch wisst.
Weil ihr wisst ja, mit Arch-Usern ist was bei
wie mit Veganern.
Reboot,
also ich muss mal nicht rebooten,
sondern die erzählen es dir von sich aus.
Und ich bin Arch-Leanungs-User,
Beste, kann ich jedem nur
empfehlen.
Welches Handy hast du eigentlich? Ich hab ein iPhone 14 Pro.
Ich hab vorhin gesagt, wo es ums iPhone
15 Pro geht, dass ich das preislich nicht
einsehe, mir da ein neues zu kaufen.
Also,
um es genau zu nehmen, hab ich
aktuell ein iPhone 14
Pro und
ein iPhone 12 ist das, glaube ich,
aber das eine ist von der Firma
und das andere ist halt meins.
Ja, das kann man sich ja mal gönnen
dann. Aber ganz ehrlich, noch mal
1300 Euro einfach für so einen komischen
Side-Button
muss nicht wirklich sein,
gell?
Tim, wo wir grad beim Thema sind,
ich wollte mir eigentlich das Video angucken,
warum man sich doch jetzt
unbedingt das iPhone 15 Pro Max
kaufen sollte. Um es da einzugehen, aber was gewinne ich
eigentlich wirklich? Und um das herauszufinden,
habe ich dieses Mal.
Also, das Einzige, was das iPhone 15 hat,
ist den Action-Button, den finde ich ganz
cool.
Auch das normale Pro und
das iPhone 15 genommen und
ihn auf die relativ farblosen
Zähne gefühlt. Bin nur für dieses Video
extra nach Frankfurt gefahren und
habe noch andere Experimente, nennen wir es mal
unter anderem. Frankfurt-Pudi!
Goethe-Straße,
Louis-Vuitton-Store,
zahl die Kollektion bar,
fick auf Sponsor, kann ich
dazu nur sagen.
Vielleicht auch ein
kleineres oder ein günstigeres
Telefon genügt. Viel Spaß!
Initiale
Tests der iPhones habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon gesehen
oder sie interessieren euch nicht. Und
da das hier auch kein Kanal ist, wo ich euch einfach
Farben von allen Handys zeigen kann oder
absichtlich mein Telefon zerbreche,
ich kaufe die Sachen halt von
But why?
meinem Geld und muss sie hinterher entweder weiterverkaufen
oder in der Familie verteilen. Also
muss ich mich hier bodenständig noch um
echte Inhalte kümmern. Ich habe mir meinen
Ich habe damals, als
ich glaube Steve Jobs
noch gab, mal
in Frankfurt beim Apple-Store
Leute davor übernachten sehen und das
hat mich echt verstört damals.
Was macht ihr das? Ihr könnt euch das einfach im
Internet bestellen. Das ging damals ja auch schon.
Ihr müsst hier nicht davor
sitzen, aber die fanden das geil.
Für die war das so ein
schon irgendwie so eine
Pilgerreise fast, könnte man sagen.
Es gibt ja Studien
zu, dass solche
Sachen für viele Leute heutzutage
Religionsersatz sind. Das sage jetzt nicht
ich, da gibt es wirklich Untersuchungen zu.
Und das war für die so eine Art
Pilgerreise zum Apple-Store.
Dann mit Gleichgesinnten da getroffen
und haben da übernachtet. Das fand ich
echt etwas verstörend.
Ist aber schon ein bisschen her.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es heute immer noch
die Apple-Store Camper gibt.
Wahrscheinlich, aber nicht mehr so viele. Die meisten
werden es dann wahrscheinlich auch im Internet bestellen.
Für die Leute
nicht.
... in blau gekauft. Meine Frau bekommt das
iPhone Pro in weißem
Titan und beim iPhone
15 ist es sowieso fast egal, weil es
immer weiß aussieht. Du musst schon sehr genau
hinschauen, um hier ein bisschen
Erdbeermilch drin zu sehen, die
Apple als pink verkauft. Aber es kommt ja auf die
inneren Werte an und ich stecke das Ding am Ende sowieso
in eine Hülle, oder? Dann ist es auch ein bisschen
egal. Ja, ich stecke es in eine Hülle.
Man muss das ja in eine Hülle stecken,
weil die Kamera so fett ist.
Die Kamera ist so fett, dass du das Ding nicht mehr ordentlich
auf den Tisch legen kannst, ohne dass es klabbert die ganze Zeit.
Lasst uns mal über das Äußerliche
sprechen. Die neuen Titan-Gehäuse
für die Pro-Modelle sind einfach schon ein deutliches
Upgrade. Das Handy ist merklich
leichter und die matteren, leicht
abgerundeten Seiten schmeicheln
meinen Händen auch deutlich mehr.
In den iPhones Pro
werkelt der neue A17
Pro-Prozessor im Inneren und
bietet einfach mehr Leistung, als die meisten von uns
sinnvoll nutzen können werden.
Außer ihr nutzt die iPhones auch gleichzeitig
als Spielekonsole. Das sieht tatsächlich schon
relativ beeindruckend aus. Ich mag durchsichtige
Hüllen nicht. Ich hatte eine Weile
von der Firma so eine durchsichtige Hülle
in der alten Arbeit, aber das hat mir nie gefallen.
Eindruckend aus, aber ich habe keine Zeit zum Zocken.
Ich muss ja schließlich dieses Video machen.
Und was uns die Mehrleistung tatsächlich im Alltag
für einzelne Funktionen, wie Kamera
und vielleicht auch den USB-Port
Ich behaupte einfach mal, die Mehrleistung wirst du gar
nicht großartig spüren.
Schauen wir uns gleich nochmal in den Infos an.
Und ich hatte einfach keine Lust, hier jetzt groß
irgendwie mit synthetischen Benchmarks
rum zu benchmarken, denn künstliche Zahlen
zu zeigen, die sowieso keinem helfen,
können gerne andere machen. Und vor allem
ist es Arbeit. Und die habe ich lieber in den
Kameravergleich gesteckt und in den USB-Port.
Und in den Action-Button.
Über den Lautstärketasten haben wir jetzt den
Action-Button, den du wie bisher
mit Ruheschaltung belegen kannst.
Das Menü sieht ein bisschen
komisch aus, irgendwie.
Fast schon ein bisschen billig.
Fokus-Modus
oder die Kamera starten oder die Taschenlampe
oder eine Sprachnotiz, was auch immer.
Ich habe mich allerdings dafür entschieden,
darauf eine kleine Eskalation zu legen.
Denn du kannst damit auch einen Shortcut auslösen.
Und hey, wenn ich einen Shortcut benutzen kann,
dann löse ich einen Shortcut aus.
Moment, ich zeige ihn euch.
Mein Action-Button-Shortcut überprüft als erstes,
ob ein Fokus-Modus gesetzt ist
oder welcher gesetzt ist.
Wenn mein Handy im Schlaf-Modus ist, dann schaltet der Tastendruck.
Genau für sowas hätte ich
auch gerne einen Action-Button.
Also ich würde damit wahrscheinlich
nicht irgendeine feste Funktion triggern,
sondern wirklich irgendeine Art Skript.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau was,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
ich könnte es gut gebrauchen.
Aber der Button alleine ist es mir nicht wert,
ein neues Handy zu kaufen.
Die Taschenlampe an.
Und zwar lässt sich bei einem Shortcut
die Helligkeit auch noch geringer stellen,
als wenn man das hier über
das Control Center macht.
Ach echt?
Denn wenn ich nachts zu den Kindern muss
und da, was weiß ich, einen Schnuller neben dem Bett suchen,
dann brenne ich nicht mir und meinen Kindern die...
Geht das auch für die Display-Helligkeit?
Ich gucke ja gerne abends im Bett
noch ein bisschen streamen
und
ich würde gerne das Display
noch ein bisschen dunkler stellen.
Die Netzhaut weg.
Wenn ich nicht schlafen sollte,
überprüft das iPhone,
in welcher Position es sich befindet.
Und dafür brauchst du die App Actions,
weil Shortcuts diese Daten sonst nicht zur Verfügung stellt.
Und halte ich dann mein Handy quer,
während ich da drauf drücke,
dann startet es die Kamera im Video-Modus
direkt auf. Das ist tatsächlich super,
um irgendwelche Situationen mit den Kindern
oder auch was für irgendwelche Gears hier nicht zu verpassen.
Verstehe ich. Gätte ich. Das klingt praktisch.
Wenn ich im Hochformat drauf drücke, dann nehme ich an,
dass ich einen Beleg scannen möchte.
Dafür habe ich nochmal einen eigenen Shortcut,
der ein Dokument scannt, das in meinen Ordner sortiert
und dann... Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Finde ich gut durchdacht.
...per Mail ans Heftdisk schickt.
Wenn das Handy mit dem Gesicht nach unten
zum Beispiel auf dem Tisch liegt und ich diesen Knopf drücke,
dann ist es so eine Art Panik-Button,
wenn ein Geräusch aus dem Handy kommt,
was nicht rauskommen soll, dann wird einfach alles
stumm geschaltet. Und am Ende,
wenn das Ganze über Kopf sich befindet,
während ich da drauf drücke,
dann befindet es sich in der Regel in der Hosentasche
und dann kann ich damit meinen Podcast
pausieren oder weiterlaufen lassen.
Damit experimentiere ich gerade noch.
Eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Weil ich nicht sicher bin, ob ich damit nicht doch eher
eine Sprachnotiz starten möchte,
wie so ein altes Diktiergerät.
In meinen Augen ist der Action-Button
auf jeden Fall ein Gewinn.
Und man kann damit auch lustig rumspielen
und in so einen Shortcut eskalieren.
Ich habe gesehen, dass viele auch einen Shortcut aus...
Also die Idee finde ich echt gut.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich auch
irgendein Workflow-Zeug hinterlegen
für den Action-Button. Hätte ich einen Action-Button,
aber ich habe keinen Action-Button.
Und ich gebe auch keine 1300 Euro
oder 1004. Und wie viel kostet das Ding jetzt?
Also nicht die Max, sondern nur die normale
Pro-Variante. Wie kostet das jetzt?
Sind Pro bei?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Habe sogar schon mal geguckt.
Ja, hier, 1200 Euro.
Also ich gebe jetzt keine 1200 Euro aus,
um einen neuen Knopf zu bekommen.
Partner darauf legen, dann geht eben
ein Menü auf, wo ihr euch
einzelne Aktionen aussuchen könnt.
Aber für mich soll der Action-Button eine Action machen
und nicht meine Action unterbrechen,
indem ich noch was auswähle.
Ein weiteres neues Feature, aber für alle
halbwegs aktuellen iPhones in iOS 17,
an dem ich mich sehr erfreue, ist Standby.
Das ist die Möglichkeit, dein Handy einfach in ein
Status-Display zu verwandeln, wenn es auf einer
Ladestation, so wie hier, vor sich hin lädt.
Und ein paar passende Optionen
dafür hat der heutige Sponsor ESR
im Rücken.
Ich würde das permanent aus Versehen runterschmeißen,
wenn das bei mir hier irgendwie
auf dem Schreibtisch oder so hängen würde.
Bei mir liegt das Handy im Prinzip
eingesteckt, irgendwo
per USB irgendwo in der Ecke.
Oder ich hab's dabei in der Hose.
Oder ich sitze irgendwo und mach drauf was.
Also, das brauch ich nicht.
Für irgendwelche Dashboards hab ich meine
Fire HD Templates an der Wand.
Damit kann man das auch alles gut steuern.
Und deine
Apple Watch gleichzeitig da aufladen.
Und der steht auf meinem Nachttisch.
Wie viel kostet dieser Stand? Ach so, das ist
nichts Offizielles von Apple. Dann verstehe ich's.
Dann ist okay. Dann geht das preislich wahrscheinlich,
gäbe es sowas von Apple, würde es mal
mindestens 999 Euro kosten.
Jetzt gerade steht er hier und zeigt
mir nachts dann deutlich augenschonender als jetzt
Uhrzeit und ein paar HomeKit-Buttons.
Und wenn du dein Handy damit schnell lädst,
kann der mit seiner Cryo-Boost-
Lüftertechnik das iPhone auch kühlen.
Besonders ist bei der ganzen Geschichte
What?
dass du nichts mitbringen musst. Du musst dir
keinen MagSafe Puck kaufen und den
ersten
iPhone laden, so wie ich
in deinem Reitort auf Welcherung ansehe.
Spiel E-Stützung DC. Und neben der Tat,
in der Hölle, dass ich in Zukunft fast
nur noch eine Art von Kabel überall hin
mitnehmen muss, brennt in der Hölle.
Tipptäuschtel. Was gibt es für USB-C?
Die halten schon haufenweise zu.
Ich habe mir vor ein paar Jahren
mal, da war USB-C
noch gar nicht so verbreitet.
Da habe ich mir mal ein paar USB-Kabel
gekauft. Die haben
Micro-USB, USB-C
und
Lightning vorne dran.
Das war eine gute Entscheidung.
Die sind
kaum schwerer durch diese
3 Stecker und
man muss sich überhaupt keine Gedanken
mehr machen. Ich glaube,
der einzige Nachteil, den man damit hat,
ich glaube, man kann damit kein
USB-C 3
äh
wie heißt das?
Quick Charge 3.0
oder irgendwie sowas machen.
Haben diese Kabel auch Markerchips?
Ne, die werden bestimmt nicht als Original
Kabel erkannt. Ne, ne, ne. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und einen sehr umfassenden
Standard. Und ich habe da ein bisschen rumprobiert
und ich würde sagen, ich gehe mal an den Andreas
kurz nach dem Release.
Wir fangen einfach mal an.
Ich habe hier diesen Sateki USB-C Hub
und den stecken wir hier einfach mal ran an den Vogel.
Und es passiert
nicht so viel. Aber
ich habe hier zum Beispiel ein Netzwerkkabel liegen.
Und jetzt gucken wir einfach mal. Ich bin jetzt
mit völlig
ausgeschalteten Daten
weiterhin online.
Verrückt.
Wo kommen wir da hin?
Dass man per USB auf einmal an Geräte
wieder Sachen anschließen kann.
Internet, iPhone.
Wir haben HDMI. Passiert
da was?
Ich kann den hier jetzt auch
eben mit aufnehmen. Speicherkarten.
Ich würde sagen,
da fischen wir hier mal die kleine aus der Drohne.
Stecken die hier rein.
Und jetzt müsste ja eigentlich in der
Files-App. Ja, ist auf jeden Fall
eines der besten Sachen am neuen iPhone. Ja, sehe
ich auch so. Endlich USB-C.
Das sind Drohnenaufnahmen.
Auch wenn man sich erstmal dazu zwingen musste.
Dass man direkt auf externe Datenträger aufnehmen kann.
Dafür habe ich diesen USB-C
USB-Stick. Und Apple-Leute regen
sich über alles auf. Wir stecken den mal an und gucken,
was passiert. Nichts.
Und freuen sich über jeden Furz von Apple.
Also den höheren Daten-Codec.
Der taucht an dem USB-C
Port ein USB-C-Label auf.
So, jetzt mache ich ein Video
von der Kappe von diesem Ding
zu 4K mit ProRes-Log.
Dann gucken wir mal, wie einfach wir
jetzt an die Daten rankommen.
Oh nein! Man kann Daten
wieder über einen USB-Stick austauschen.
Und ja, im Apple-Ökosystem
ist das nicht so einfach,
Daten einfach auszutauschen.
Muss man sich erstmal überlegen.
Wie kriegt man die Daten runter?
Stöpselt
man das an wie früher
und geht dann über USB 2.0 und kopiert
das?
Oder verschickt man es sich per Mail?
Haben ja auch manche gemacht.
Uploadet man
das in die Cloud? Apple schwebt
natürlich vor. Am besten ist, man synkt alles
direkt in die Apple-Cloud und Ruhe ist.
Oder, was ich sehr cool finde,
ich habe vergessen aus dem Kopf,
wie die App heißt. Ich habe so eine
File Explorer
App.
Die kann auf dem iPhone
Dateien sharen.
Entweder über einen Web-Server
oder sogar auch über Samba.
Aber da kann man dann einfach mit einem Browser
auf die IP vom iPhone gehen
und kann sich das runterziehen.
Das fand ich immer ganz praktisch.
Natürlich schon ziemlich gut.
Ein bisschen schade natürlich, dass es jetzt nur offenbar
mit ProRes-Aufnahmen geht.
Also wenn ich mal eine längere Zeitraffer-Aufnahme
oder einfach ein langes
Video aufnehmen will, das wäre ja schon
einfach angenehmer, das eben hier
aufzuschmeißen und dann hinterher dahin zu
ziehen, wo ich es weiter benutzen will.
Dann soll das Ganze ja auch andere
Geräte laden können. Ich habe jetzt hier mal die
USB-C-Airpods, aber das müsste mit den
Lightning-Airpods genauso gehen. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob
der Vogel auflädt.
Er lädt auf.
Ich kann unterwegs auch
andere Geräte damit laden.
Ich glaube, Documents habe ich...
Ich glaube, das könnte es sogar sein.
Das hat er auf jeden Fall nicht genug
Power, um das zu betreiben.
Aber wir gucken mal, ob
mein Mikrofon... Und offenbar habe
ich hier auf
TikTok oder YouTube Shorts gelernt,
dass man dieses Mikrofon jetzt auch benutzt,
um es in der Hand zu halten.
Es funktioniert mit mehr Dingen, als
ich erwartet hätte. Aber es funktioniert.
Nicht ganz so viel Spaß macht es auf dem
Nicht-Pro-iPhone, weil der alte Chip,
der hier drin ist, einfach...
Bei Mikrofon muss ich immer an die Pressekonferenz denken,
wo ich glaube, der Sony-Typ oder wer...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war. Ich glaube, der Sony-Typ,
der das Mikrofon einfach hinter sich, hinter die
Tasche gepfeffert hat.
Kennt das noch jemand? Warte mal.
Sony. Ich finde...
Ich weiß nicht... Ich weiß auch nicht,
ob das der Sony-Typ war.
Es kam wegen so einer Pressekonferenz.
Da wurde...
Es war irgendeine Spiele-Messe,
Presseveranstaltung.
Da wurde einem der Leute,
die dort interviewt wurden
oder halt auf der Couch saßen,
mit dem Mikrofon in die Hand gedrückt,
den Text gesagt. Beim Aufstehen
guckt er so links-rechts,
weiß nicht wohin mit dem Mikrofon,
pfeffert es einfach hinter sich,
hinter die Couch, läuft weg.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war.
Irgendwie muss ich immer daran denken,
wenn Leute so mit Mikrofon rumwedeln.
Aber ändert sich durch USB-C für euch
was in den neuen Möglichkeiten?
Ich freue mich tatsächlich ja auf Zubehör...
Keine Lightning-Stecker mehr.
Womit ich mein externes Mikro
mit einem USB-Port schließen kann,
einen weiteren Datenträger an einen zweiten
und eine Powerbank vielleicht an einen dritten.
Oder die ist vielleicht sogar integriert.
Vielleicht ist auch ein Datenträger integriert.
Irgendwas, was ich hier drauf klemmen kann.
Ich meine, ich habe ja schon einen
iPhone-Halter fürs Film von Moment.
Und ich freue mich einfach auf eine Zukunft,
wo ich wirklich etwas für professionelle
Kameraaufnahmen mit dem iPhone
kaufen kann.
Und was für ein Zufall, damit sind wir schon
bei den Kameras. Und ein paar Dinge
habe ich ja eben schon gezeigt.
Und das macht es einfach so viel besser
mit dem iPhone zu drehen.
Das alte Pro war wie gesagt 20 mal langsamer,
um diese riesigen ProRes-Dateien
darunter zu kratzen.
Und am Ende war es oft einfach schneller
AirDrop zu benutzen, wenn es dann
funktioniert hat.
Du bist wahrscheinlich sogar über
ein modernes Wi-Fi deutlich schneller
unterwegs, als das ganze über USB-2
Geschwindigkeit rüber zu kopieren.
Was übrigens auch immer noch USB-2
heißt.
Ihr dürft jetzt allerdings nicht auf die Idee kommen, dass
USB-3 noch USB-3 heißt.
Weil das ist falsch. Aber USB-2
heißt immer noch USB-2.
Meistens ging das, aber es ist Funk.
Und dann funktioniert es einfach nie
zu 100%. Jetzt ziehe ich
einfach den Stick ab und stecke es in den Rechner
und alles ist fertig.
Leider sind da die Möglichkeiten von Apple aktuell ja ein bisschen
eingeschränkt und ich kann nicht ohne weiteres
entscheiden, vielleicht auch ein Fotoshooting
direkt da drauf zu machen. Oder vor allem
nicht ProRes-Videos oder irgendwelche
langen Zeitrafferaufnahmen direkt auf einen
externen Datenträger zu speichern.
Für mich passt das, für andere vielleicht nicht.
Und dann habe ich, wie eingangs schon gesagt,
auch Vergleichsbilder gemacht.
Mit dem iPhone 15 Pro Max.
Mit dem iPhone 15 Pro
und dem iPhone 15 Pro Max.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es kaum Unterschiede
und wenn es Unterschiede gibt, dann ist es
irgendein Post-Processing, der jetzt ein bisschen
anders ist.
Und als Referenz dem iPhone 14 Pro Max.
Es gibt bei der ganzen Geschichte
100.000 Fallstricke und das iPhone
rechnet sich ja bei vielen Sachen
auch das Bild aus
mehreren Kameras zusammen.
Bei verschiedenen Lichtstärken dann
nicht mehr oder erst recht oder Lichtpixel
zusammen oder auch nicht. Das übersteigt dann
meine Fähigkeiten irgendwie einen absolut
wissenschaftlichen Test zu liefern.
Und wenn die Ergebnisse wenigstens
grob richtig sind, ich würde sagen,
das ist der Anspruch, mit dem ich hier reingehe.
Im Wesentlichen interessiert mich
auch dabei die Schnappschussqualität.
Also wie es sich im Alltag
mit relativen Standardeinstellungen
schlägt. Wenn ich rausgehen möchte
und irgendwie eine Langzeitbelichtung
oder ein Landschaftsbild in RAW machen
will, dann habe ich meistens meine große Kamera
dabei, wo der Sensor größer ist
und auch die Linse.
Okay, das stimmt wohl.
Der Vorteil von so einem iPhone
ist halt schon
irgendwo, dass es ziemlich gute Bilder macht
und du es immer dabei hast.
Mich interessiert vielmehr,
wie die Kameras sich auch drinnen schlagen
bei nicht perfektem Licht und
vielleicht bei herumlaufenden Kindern.
Also das muss ich sagen, da bin ich echt
positiv überrascht von den letzten paar
iPhones schon gewesen. Ich habe
beispielsweise mal im fast dunklen
Schrank meine Cats
fotografiert und
die haben ja so einen
Nachtbeleuchtungsmodus
oder sowas, wo du dann glaub
irgendwie fünf Sekunden oder so die Kamera
halten musst.
Das sah richtig gut aus danach.
...Wahrsphäre meiner Kinder
zu schützen... Also viel heller, als ich es
mit den Augen gesehen habe. Also für meine
Testbilder. Und meine Erkenntnisse sind,
die Kamera ist super.
Also die Hauptkamera.
Und die ist an allen
drei... Das Bild von der Katze habe ich garantiert
auf Twitter irgendwann mal gepostet.
Das ist aber schon zwei, drei Jahre her. Das finde ich
jetzt so spontan nicht... Aktuellen
iPhone-Kamera-Sets
relativ gleich. In den Pro-Modellen
ist sie zwei Millimeter weitwinkliger.
Dies, das. Und Apple hat auch nicht
offiziell gesagt, dass das der gleiche
Sensor ist. Aber die technischen Daten sind
ähnlich genug.
Sind ähnlich genug. Und die
Ergebnisse auch. Beim neuen Zweifach-Zoom,
wo einfach die Mitte des Sensors ausgelesen
wird, bevor die gesamte Bildverarbeitung
darüber gejagt wird, ist es
auch tatsächlich überraschend gut
und super. Das Ganze bietet auf jeden Fall
eine bessere Bildqualität,
als die alleinstehende
Weitwinkelkamera. Tatsächlich nimmt
das für Menschen, die vielleicht nur
ein bisschen mehr Zoom brauchen,
einen Grund, vom
iPhone auf das iPhone Pro
abzugraden. Wenn du dann darüber hinauszoomst,
also wenn du beim Dreifach-Zoom
ankommst, dann schlägt das Pro aber
wieder das Nicht-Pro, weil es dafür eben
eine eigene Kamera hat. Das iPhone
Pro Max hat diese Dreifach-Kamera
nicht, sondern eine mit fünffachen Zoom.
Wenn du mit dem Pro Max auf
Dreifachen-Zoom fotografierst,
ist darum das Bild hieraus schlechter
Bisschen schlechter, ja.
Ja, okay, das leuchtet
sich ein, weil es für diese Zoom-Stufe
dann ein bisschen hochrechnen muss.
Weird Champ.
Als aus dem iPhone 15 Pro.
Weil es sich eben die Zoom-Stufe aus der normalen
Kamera und aus dem
Fünffach-Zoom ausdenken muss.
Es ist aber besser, als beim
iPhone 15, das einfach nur
einen kleinen Ausschnitt vom Hauptkamerasensor
nehmen kann. Ich hoffe, dem
ganzen kann man noch folgen. Das 15 Pro
Max hat aber fast so gut wie die Benahmung
von Microsoft-Produkten, ja, eben
den Fünffach-Zoom. Und ich hatte ein bisschen Angst
vor der Qualität, die aus diesem
Prismen-Spiegel-Objektiv-Ding
Kabinettteil rausfallen.
Ich muss jetzt aber sagen, nachdem
ich mir die ganzen auch auf
3, 4, 500 Prozent verglichen
habe, dass die auf einem
relativ gleichen Bildqualitätsniveau
wie der Dreifach-Zoom
beim Pro liegen. Nur
eben weiter reingezoomt.
Und bei schlechteren und sehr schlechten
Lichtverhältnissen spielen die Pros
auch. Also ich fände Fünffach-Zoom bei
meinem iPhone gar nicht verkehrt, weil
ich benutze das tatsächlich manchmal,
um weit entfernte Schilder
und so ran zu zoomen.
Also unter
bestimmten Bedingungen
erkennt man,
aber jetzt auch nicht viel,
erkennt man weit entfernte Sachen,
das ist bei meinem iPhone 14 reingezoomt
besser als mit bloßen Augen.
Nicht alles, aber gerade
Schrift auf Schildern,
die weit weg sind, die man nicht mal richtig lesen kann
und es gerade so an der Grenze ist,
wo man es nicht mehr lesen kann,
dann bringt das was.
Ihre Stärke vermutlich
durch den stärkeren Prozessor aus.
Die Bilder sind einfach sauberer,
die sind auch nicht immer scharf, aber ich hatte
auf jeden Fall eine bessere
Schärfequote. Und wenn
die Bilder scharf sind und wenn ihr die
gleichen Bilder ungefähr gleich scharf bekommt,
dann sehen sie einfach ein bisschen besser aus.
Und bei gesoomten Bildern auf den
mittleren Sensorausschnitt multipliziert
sich das noch ein bisschen und sieht dann hier
schon schwächer aus. Aber was lernen
wir denn jetzt daraus?
Die Kamera im 15er ist
in der Summe einfach die schlechteste.
Aber sie ist verdammt gut.
Unterschiede siehst du vor allem bei nicht
nativen Zoom-Leveln und zwar bei höheren
und bei weniger Licht.
Da kommt einfach die neue Verarbeitung
der schnelleren Prozessoren-Image-Pipeline
der Pro-Modelle als Sieger aus.
Bei Tageslicht
ist das in meinen nicht wissenschaftlichen
Tests aber ziemlich gleichwertig.
Und auch der Zweifach-Zoom spielt dann in der
gleichen Liga. Für alles weiter gesoomte
schlagen dann die Pro-Modelle
die Nicht-Pro-Modelle. Und ehrlich gesagt
ist das auch keine Überraschung.
Die Kamera zwischen Pro und Pro Max
unterscheidet sich in den Zoom-Stufen.
Aber ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass die im Pro Max
eine andere Kamera ist. Die hat einfach eine
andere native Brennweite. Das wäre bei
einer normalen Kamera
als hättest du dir einfach ein anderes Objektiv
für die gleiche Kamera gekauft.
Da kommt es einfach darauf an, was du fotografierst
und wie.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde den Kauf
da zwischen dem Pro und dem Pro Max
nicht von der Kamera abhängig machen.
Sondern ob ich halt ein größeres Handy
will oder nicht.
In dem Preissegment
macht das Geld wahrscheinlich
mal auch den Unterschied aus.
Ich habe absichtlich ein normales Pro gekauft.
Nicht weil es irgendwie 200 Euro
billiger ist oder irgendwie was mit der Kamera
oder so. Sondern weil mir das
schon fast ein bisschen zu groß ist.
Ich fotografiere ganz gern
mit längeren Brennweiten.
Ich kann den Bildern oft einfach mehr abgewinnen
als Weitwinkeln. Aber andere
fotografieren sehr viel mehr mit
Weitwinkel. Und darum ist es ganz praktisch
vielleicht einfach mal zu schauen,
mit welchen Brennweiten du eigentlich wirklich
fotografierst. In der Fotos-App am Mac
kannst du dafür intelligente Alben
anlegen, um die Verteilung nachvollziehen
zu können. Für mich persönlich ist der
5-fach-Zoom hiervon super. Aber ich kann mir sehr gut
vorstellen, dass viele mit dem 3-fach-Zoom
im Alltag einfach besser fahren.
Was du bei den Pros aber eben auch bekommst,
ist die Möglichkeit, in RAW zu fotografieren.
Also mit mehr Auflösung
und weniger Nachbearbeitung.
Die musst du dann allerdings auch abliefern.
Sonst sehen die
normalen Bilder direkt.
Wo ist er denn hier?
Wo ist er denn
hier am Start?
Ist das der Mindtower?
Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht
so ganz sicher, ob man da überhaupt drauf
kann. Normalen Bilder
direkt aus der Kamera einfach
besser aus. Für mich das Killer-Argument sind am Ende
die ProRes-Videoaufnahmen und die
Möglichkeit, das Ganze auf externe
Datenträger zu speichern.
ProRes-Log-Video mit der entsprechenden
Nachbearbeitung mit den Apple LUT
machen die Videos einfach weniger...
ProRes-Log-Video. Alter,
die haben für ihren Kram aber auch schon immer
krasse Bezeichnungen, wenn man sich überlegt,
was dahinter steckt. Ja, okay,
wir speichern den Output jetzt auf dem USB-Stick.
Nice.
Schärft.
Und dann ist es nicht mehr sofort als Handy-Video
zu erkennen. Und auch ein Lob
muss ich tatsächlich den neuen standardmäßigen
24 Megapixel-Bildern aussprechen.
Also die Bilder des 48 Megapixel-Sensors
werden auf 24 statt
auf 12 Megapixel runtergerechnet.
Und die Bilder sehen tatsächlich
etwas weniger überbearbeitet aus
als die Bilder aus dem
iPhone 14 Pro vom letzten Jahr.
Außer wenn du tatsächlich die RAW-Bilder vergleichst,
dann sind die wieder deutlich näher
beisammen. Aber in Alltagsbildern
schlägt das 15er Pro Max
das 14er Pro Max doch relativ
sichtbar. Und was ich mir fürs nächste
Update tatsächlich wünsche, ist ein Update
der Weitwinkelkamera. Auch wenn ich gesagt habe, dass ich
sie recht wenig benutze, aber die ist einfach
mittlerweile am weitesten zurück.
Insgesamt ist es aus meiner Sicht einfach ein
fantastisches Jahr, um sich ein iPhone zuzulegen.
Für meinen Anwendungsfall auf jeden Fall ein Pro...
Aber kein fantastisches Jahr
vom letzten Jahresmodell zu upgraden.
...modell, weil der USB-Port
bei den anderen so langsam ist, wie bei
allen iPhones bisher. Aber die neuen
Möglichkeiten aus dem Gesamtpaket
in den Pros, wenn ihr die zum Filmen nutzt,
sind einfach super. Garniert mit dem
Action-Button und dem
handschmeichlerischen Gehäuse. Ich bin sehr
zufrieden damit. Aber auch die normalen iPhones
haben einfach ein gutes Jahr erwischt. Außer
dass sie äußerlich jetzt nicht besonders
gesättigt sind, im Gegensatz zu mir.
Aber durch den Sensor-Zoom bekommst du auch
eine kleine Tele-Linse in normalen iPhones.
Und auch einen USB-C-Anschluss.
Wenn auch deutlich langsamer. Und zumindest
die Standard-Kamera-Linse
ist ziemlich... Ne, viel Neues gab's echt nicht.
Was ich tatsächlich am interessantesten
finde, ist der Action-Button und dass es
jetzt halt USB-C ist. Das war's eigentlich.
Das war's groß und ganz.
Aber wenn du nicht bei wenig Licht
sehr bewegliche Dinge fotografieren willst,
oder in RAW, was du nicht kannst,
was ich nicht ganz verstehe, weil da ja auch
der Chip aus dem letzten iPhone Pro drin ist,
muss ich vielleicht auch nicht.
Aber wenn du einfach keine Ahnung hast, was
ProRes-Video eigentlich bedeutet,
du auf keinen Fall in RAW fotografieren willst,
du den Port hier unten...
Wofür brauchst du die... Also was
bringen dir die 2 GB mehr RAM?
Was machst du? Also was muss man auf seinem iPhone
machen, dass das wirklich
quasi jetzt ne Verbesserung ist?
Maximal zum Laden nutzt
und du auf den Action-Button verzichten kannst
oder dir vielleicht sogar lieber den
Stummschalt-Schieberegler wünscht,
bekommst du auch beim iPhone 15
ein ziemlich gutes Telefon. Entscheiden
musst du dich am Ende selbst. Bist hoffentlich alt genug.
Wir haben aber, würde ich sagen,
einen sehr guten Jahrgang erwischt.
Außer bei den Hüllen.
Echt?
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich nicht am RAM, oder?
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass
Hintergrundaktivitäten und sowas nur 10 Minuten
laufen.
Ist das wirklich so, dass das nicht
ausreicht? Also kann schon sein.
Kann schon sein.
Dann ist es natürlich von Vorteil.
Wenn du dann mehrere Apps quasi gleichzeitig
immer wieder
rüber-tappen kannst.
Ja okay, das leuchtet ein.
Zapp. Danke für den Zapp.
Wie viele Tabs man offen haben kann.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das sind nicht viele. Das sind wirklich nicht viele.
Das hier sind halbwegs
viele. Aber hier habe ich letztens
aufgeräumt. Hier hatten wir auch 60
oder so offen. Das ist schon wenig
für meine Verhältnisse.
Hat er jetzt eigentlich geupgradet und ich kann rebooten?
Oder habe ich nicht sogar schon rebooted?
Chat-Gabe ich rebooted?
Ich glaube ich habe rebooted schon.
Ich reboote einfach nochmal.
Planst du das Thema AI zu bequatschen?
Nö, wüsste ich nicht was ich da noch zu sagen kann.
Was nicht schon tausend Mal gesagt wurde.
Aber ich müsste echt mal wieder ein Video
aufnehmen.
Zumal ich jetzt morgen ganzen Tag auch Zeit habe.
Warum habe ich eigentlich kein Dark-Theme mehr?
Weil ich blöd war und es umgestellt
habe, gell?
Was hatte ich denn davor immer?
Erinnert sich noch jemand?
Was hatte ich denn davor?
Eins davon.
Eins davon werde ich ja
benutzt haben.
Das da vielleicht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr.
Magenta-Keckel? Ne, bestimmt nicht.
Das da?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach das.
Schauen wir mal.
X-Neu.
PPo ist ja auch schon am Pennen.
Eigentlich ist Boomer müde, Boomer Bett
Sleepge jetzt angesagt.
Bettge.
Darf ich mich fragen, welche WM?
Das ist X, kein Wayland,
weil Wayland nicht gescheit
in der WM funktioniert.
Halt Video über Pyro? Nö.
Funktioniert doch leider nicht
mal gescheit mittlerweile.
Also zumindest auf den Seiten.
Also es funktioniert auf vielen Seiten,
aber es funktioniert auf manchen halt nicht.
Und davon sind es halt viel frequentierte Seiten wie Twitch.
Und selbst richtig
echte im Browser-Adblocker haben Probleme mit
Twitch.
Und auch in Zukunft mit YouTube.
Ist Pyro 6 ein großes Update? Ich weiß nicht.
Können theoretisch mal reingucken in das Video,
aber nicht heute,
weil ich bin jetzt echt müde.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
War eher eine spontane Sache,
da ich heute nochmal angekommen bin.
Also Leute,
morgen früh,
8.30 bis 9 Uhr,
gehen sie los. Theoretisch müsste ich
morgen eine Runde rennen,
aber nachdem ich gestern rennen war
und heute
Fahrrad fahren,
kann ich auch pünktlich Streamern machen.
Muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Aber guck mal, ich könnte mein eigenes Video empfohlen.
Ist ja sehr,
sehr nice.
Wird kalt. Ja, leider.
Leider ist der Sommer, beziehungsweise
der
ausgehende Herbst-Sommer
jetzt, das scheint jetzt vorbei zu sein.
Das ist doof.
Ich fand das gerade
aber wenn man wirklich draußen sich
ein bisschen bewegen will. Sehr, sehr
praktisch.
Aber das hat sich jetzt glaube ich erledigt.
Wo rennst du hin? 6,2
Kilometer bei mir hier
in der
Gegend rum. Ich hab da so
meine Standardroute schon.
Ich hab meine Heizung schon eingeschaltet.
Remote über den Raspberry Pi.
Kann das steuern.
Über den Raspberry Pi.
Und die Thermostate,
die hab ich auch schon eingeschaltet.
Also Leute, ich geh' pennen. Wir sehen uns.
Bis dahin macht's gut. Bis morgen früh.
See you.